[Music]
they always get this wrong in film and
television
so here we are let's try it out first
thing to remember is that the white
square always goes at the bottom right
hand corner
that's very important this is what
television always gets wrong the corner
squares are occupied by rooks
heading inwards we have the knights
these always go next to the rooks
then it's the bishops and this is the
tricky part
the king and the queen the queen always
goes on the same colour as the piece
we say that the queen's dress matches
her shoes the white queen will go on the
white square
and the black queen similarly to the
black square and therefore
the king goes next to it the pawns are
the foot soldiers they always go ahead
of their pieces
um there are eight of them they go on
these eight squares
and that's how you set up the board
[Music]
that's how you set up the board it's
very easy to get that wrong the the
the black square that's right yeah
everyone knows now everyone knows
everyone had no excuse i mean
you always do it dave is right you're
always sitting in films they get it
wrong and it's like
guys it's a 50 50 chance but 99 of the
time it's wrong so
hopefully they know now now we know okay
ladies and gentlemen the second round of
the
air things monsters is starting in just
a few minutes and let's take a look
at who will face who in round two
uh one of the games will be between my
team vajrayana
and hikaru nakamura who won that first
game he must be feeling so confident now
javanka yeah
this is a great start for him everyone
wants to start their first game off with
a victory
and it just sets the mood you know
you're feeling happy you've won your
first game
because if you're ever going to get
nervous it's going to be the first round
and you know if you lose that ground
then at that game then you're thinking
oh
this could be a bad tournament but
starting off with a victory
always good great start for hikaru now
second match
so interesting all russian matchup
between yana pomnyachi
and alexander grisham who's the favorite
here david oh this one it's so hard to
call
i mean chris rook he's one of my
favorite players we mentioned earlier
the three-time blitz world champion
at these fast time controls he's so
dangerous he can beat anyone on his day
that being said he lost in the first
round with white his debut in the
champions chess tour
i think maybe he'll just try and survive
this game he needs to make sure he
doesn't start with two losses in a row
um the nerves will be jangling a bit i
think napoli actually slight favorite
russian champion as well
recently last week so they're probably
actually favorite but
i'm cheering for sure all right well
next one lavonna ronyon who
just played their draw against the world
champion minus carlson he's going to
play the fantastic anish
geary who's the favorite you won't go oh
i don't know actually it's a difficult
one to call but actually i'm going to
say lavon oronion because he was very
lucky in his first game
and he will be feeling very relieved and
again that has to be
like almost like a victory because he
got away with it so i think he'd be
buzzing and i think
lavon is the slight favorite one slight
favorite there all right next
matchup timor rajabov from azerbaijan
he's gonna face david anton the wild
card from spain
and then the next game between hari
and he's going to play the russian
daniel dubo
but the game that we will focus on in
this next round it is
so interesting it is the game between
the two finalists in the first
tournament in the champions chess store
wesley so the winner of the skilling
open facing
the second place in the skilling open
magnus carlsen and david
is this the moment that magnus has been
waiting for now for weeks
just to get that revenge for wrestling
so that's right i think three and a half
weeks ago was that final and
i'm sure magnus again knowing him
knowing his desire to win he'll have
been sitting in his hotel
just just focusing he's knowing he needs
revenge on wesley so wesley so meanwhile
has nothing to lose i think he's won
that first tournament
he might try and take this easy go for a
draw but um yeah he'll be looking to
restrain magnus even more
what's your expectations you won't go
yeah i agree with david i think
magnus will go out or guns blazing
because he wants that moral victory as
well but uh
definitely wesley is very pragmatic he
is so difficult to beat
i think he is perhaps going to take it
solid and
leave his energy for the knockout stages
and wesley also may be one of very few
players that is able to
sort of block out that he's facing the
world champion he just
plays chess like he's playing anyone
that's right i mean in that final for
example he lost a couple of games but
he'd always bounce back every time by
winning and
that's because he's able to block that
off and if he's confident that's the
main thing with wesley confidence if
he's confident
he can definitely win this game and
wesley so the winner of the first
tournament in the champions chess store
he has white pieces
and he is making his move and magnus
just responded
that's right so we see that the openings
actually started in the same way as we
saw magnus carson's last game white
started by pushing his pawn forward
in front of his queen and we see magnus
carson has developed a night early in
the game white also bringing a night out
into the ball um towards the center of
the board the opening is all about that
center and actually we've seen magnus
carlsen do something that i've nearly
never seen him play before
a very rare opening we call this the
king's indian defense
and this one we call it a defense but
actually it's a
it's played when black wants to win when
you want a really tense game
not many trades will happen white we see
that is occupying the center
with all of his pawns white's three
pawns there in the center of the board
um that means that white normally has
control white will have more space a bit
later on black is just aiming to keep
the tension
make the opponent nervous a bit later on
um very
very interesting stuff we also see the
black has castled his king
black's brought his king to safety and
now finally counters in the center of
the board
and we talked about that a lot in the
last game pawns supporting pawns you
wanted the pawns to come on and support
the pawns
magnus just okay well now he's traded
one off
yeah he he has chosen a line that
perhaps he is
not so used to playing because i've
actually seen wesley
be very cutthroat in this opening and go
for the kill
but here he has like you said ex-traded
pawns and now we see a trade of queens
and uh now this bishop has been
developed to pin
that knight to the rook that's why
that's that's right
that's also right if we bring up i can't
talk today there's something wrong with
you
if we if we bring up the board we can
see the last few moves there have been a
few trades
and we will likely see more trades so in
this position a very tense position
there's plenty of moves white has many
many options why could castle the king
develop his bishop
instead he decided to go for a safe
option this shows to me that wesley so
is in the mood for a draw
he tries to trade the queens um those
queens leave the board and now he jumps
his bishop out as
ivanka mentioned this bishop does a
great job um
kind of x-ray vision again why uh the
black knight cannot move
because this rook behind it would be
attacked therefore
black decided okay it's time to shuffle
this rook across get out of that line of
vision and now a set of knights have
been traded
white's central pawn here is very very
strong therefore magnus carlsen
trying to get rid of that pawn and
wesley so jumping with his bishop
forward
white's bishops look fantastic right now
bit of
well supreme control really by those
bishops over some key squares
and magnus carlsen it will depend on
whether he's familiar with this position
this position has a reputation of being
quite solid for black
being quite decent for black but with
best play
should be a draw so i think wesley he's
just testing magnus he's keeping that
draw in hand he's keeping that safety
latch on
um he's just saying to magnus if you
don't know your stuff i'll punish you if
you do know your stuff
we'll just make a draw exactly no i like
this philosophy actually
because like you said magnus really
plays this opening i don't think i've
seen him too you know it must be a
handful of times that he's played
something like this
and uh this isn't the most popular we
saw john on wesley
space there we have to remember it's
only eight or nine o'clock where he is
sitting
a.m yes it is in early in the morning
and uh
yeah but you know i think we saw that
wesley actually did very well
playing in the morning so perhaps he's a
morning morning person
and magnus of course not playing or
playing in an unknown
unknown location so yeah i actually
talked to wesley about coffee because he
told me he
loves coffee but he never drinks coffee
when he's playing a chess tournament
because he he feels he gets too much
energy from it he gets anxious
so we know for sure that wesley hasn't
drinking coffee today even if it's early
in the morning for him
maybe that explains his kind of calm
very calm demeanor calm style on the
board as well
um and we do see a very calm position
right now
the queens have left white pieces nicely
centralized white did retreat his knight
there he's aiming for a slightly more
active square
a bit later on normally the only reason
these gu these top guys these top
players they ever retreat
is if the piece is on on the way to a
better square so um
yeah i kind of like what wesley's doing
but i think magnus he will be frustrated
he'll be so disappointed that he hasn't
got a really
kind of dynamic um kind of double-edged
fight
that he was aiming for when he played
this this opening that isn't normally
part of his
uh his repertoire yeah i mean you can
actually just look at his expression
he's so he's so expressive isn't he just
uh you know he's not happy
this wasn't really what he part of the
deal that he wanted he wanted a kind of
cutthroat game
he's not getting that so uh yes now he
just
has to just first of all equalize
and then play for playful for what
happens
that's right and with his last move we
see um on the board there
magnus carlsen he's just brought his
bishop forward challenging
white's light-squared bishop those
bishops are likely to leave the board
over the next two or three moves the
pieces are slowly starting to disappear
i slightly prefer white's position
just because the black bishop the black
dark squared bishop next to the black
king that bishop's actually blocked by
its own pawn at the moment
so that piece is not going to be very
active at least for the foreseeable
future
but if the rooks leave the board if
everything else gets traded off
just the fact that the pawn structure is
almost symmetrical
it's going to be very hard for either
side to win neither side will be able to
create a past pawn and get pawn to the
end of the board
that's the one of the only ways to win
actually once the queens leave once
checkmate is
unlikely and there we see the bishops
are traded off
um i think this one is edging slightly
closer to the draw
already yeah there's still a lot of life
there's still there's definitely still a
lot of life but definitely there's a
kind of
if you can see the there's no kind of
porn majorities on either side of the
board so it's going to be
tricky to kind of create a passport it
all depends now on who can mobilize
their pieces in the best way
and both sides actually have very active
pieces
and uh we are getting some photos on
instagram
wow i like that that last photo of that
kid playing chess
fantastic yes i hope this this board i
mean i hope it was someone's christmas
present
that looked impressive didn't it all
right we do see some moves and i'm i'm
noticing that wesley uh hasn't um
castled yet that's right so wesley has
kept his king in the middle of the board
sometimes especially once the queens
have left as we saw in that last game
with
and sometimes the king's actually better
in the middle if it won't be in danger
if a checkmate won't happen
then kings can be great when they're
centralized so um
magnus carson with his last move
offering a trade of rooks
we've seen the queens leave the board
we've seen a pair of bishops a pair of
knights
we will see a pair of rooks leave the
board soon i expect wesley actually
not to castle his king i expect wesley
to just shuffle his king forward one
square
connecting the white rooks white's rook
on the bottom right hand corner there
is not doing anything he needs to get
that in the game yeah and in fact this
position
it's been seen before played about about
10 times
really yes even after 18 moves even
after 18 moves
but uh okay now we are a new territory
no one has ever
shuffled their king forward this is new
yeah i think it might be new but it's
not a kind of groundbreaking discovery
and i think actually the fact that this
position has been seen before
is reflected in the clock times both
players they've played so quickly
they've both
still got 14 minutes on the clock um
quite possibly they've studied this
exact position before or at least
something very similar
and um yeah i mean i'm a big big fan of
wesley so he won the skilling open he's
a fantastic player but sometimes i just
think with white
a bit more ambition might elevate him to
that very very top level
to compete with magnus carlsen for world
championship titles
this game it does look like it's about
to fizzle out
there's simply nothing anyone can do to
sort of
it's it's just very balanced both
players have the same kind of um
formation of pieces the pawn structure
is symmetrical yeah and we're going to
see a trade of of rooks
and now wesley has advanced one of his
queen side for
his left spawns on the left side of the
board forward
and uh yeah yeah now that black bishop i
mentioned that bishop was blocked in
that was the only bad thing about
black's position
and now magnus carson he's sorted out
that problem black's piece
and the bishop retreats but that bishop
has a very nice long diagonal to
um just to have some fun on i think that
blackbear
will try and jump forward at some point
wesley meanwhile needs to improve that
white rook in the
bottom right corner it's just doing
nothing right now it needs to enter the
game somehow
yeah and uh one of the interesting
things about this is that the players
cannot offer a draw
they have to yes they they have to play
30 moves and then they
and if they're going to offer agree a
draw it's going to be done by repeating
the position
three times so this is actually really
nice because normally
the players could go draw and they'll go
yep and then they would carry on for the
next game
but this way you know they have to play
it out and sometimes
they will make mistakes and uh flips
yes yes or trigger happy hand moves
yeah yeah at least magnus he's traded
off the queens already so we won't see a
repeat of last
uh the last event where he mouse slipped
the whole queen this time a female slips
it won't be as bad he actually got off
to a great start in this tournament
compared to the last one
where he lost the first game with a mile
slip that was a horrible start for him
he did come back strong a bit of a
different start from
for the world champion today he started
with a draw
and might also do it during the second
round here that's right and actually
traditionally he's quite a slow starter
we saw
last last event but it's just a trend
throughout his whole career he often
loses one of his first couple of games
but then maybe that just gives him the
motivation to fight harder
um in the rest and i think a draw
against um
levon aronian against wesley so two of
his strongest rivals
i think they will um he'll be relatively
happy he won't be too disappointed
obviously killer mode he wants to
activate it but saving it for the
knockout stages
um is equally viable meanwhile wesley so
just retreats his bishop
white's bishop knight and king there
nicely coordinated all defending each
other
um i do expect magnus carson to maybe
move his knight
maybe jump forward with his bishop lots
and lots of choice for
for magnus here he could also just start
to bring the black king
closer towards the center black's king
doesn't need to be tucked away in the
corner there
it's safe but it would be even better in
the middle of the ward controlling lots
of squares
yeah definitely i agree with you that
king would be
better in the center and it's just uh
again again i mean it's very difficult
to actually come
up with a plan here because it's much
more straightforward when there's like a
porn majority on one side and you're
like push
i want to make a queen and here it's all
about just improving the pieces and
there you see
magnus has now placed his bishop on a
much more active square
and uh wesley is now up to wesley to
find the move
that's right and maybe if we bring up
the analysis board we can see what both
players will be thinking about right now
we've mentioned the pawn structure is
roughly symmetrical
um wow wesley so i chose a good moment
to bring the ball up wesley so he's
kind of gambited upon he's pushed this
pawn forward it's not defended he's
attacking the black bishop he's asking
that bishop a question
do you want to capture this knight do
you want to capture this pawn
do you want to run away and retreat
knowing magnus he definitely doesn't
want to retreat
um but if he trades for this knight i
think
actually maybe white's bishop is
slightly stronger than the knight
bishops are better when there's pawns on
both sides of the board because they're
long-range pieces
the bishop can control the right control
the left white uh the black knight it's
very short-range piece
it can only kind of it takes a long time
takes three four moves to jump over to
the other side
so i think this wouldn't favor magnus
carlsen but if he gets greedy if he
grabs a pawn
then we see the idea behind wesley so's
move this rook which was doing nothing
the whole game can now swing across
attacking this bishop and suddenly again
i keep using this phrase but
x-ray once this bishop moves white's
rook will capture
a pawn on the left side here and white's
rook would suddenly go from the worst
piece on the board
to the best piece so i think this is
something that wesley
is hoping for and that magnus should
avoid so we're going to be interested to
see what magnus chooses for his next
move here
uh probably shouldn't move uh his black
bishop then
to trade off or to to take that pawn
that's right i definitely wouldn't
capture the pawn um as black right now
trading the bishop for the night i don't
think it's a huge mistake it should
still be fine
um but it's just not something that he
uh maybe wanted magnus carson with his
last move
um i just think that's incredibly uh
clever by wesley so i just didn't expect
that and
i think that's why he's such a dangerous
player especially at these speed events
he sees things that others
would take a much longer time to see
yeah no
he's a very very natural player you know
and he definitely
he's practically unbeatable when he
wants to be and i really love
this last move because it's just asking
magnus what are you going to do
are you going to step back with a bishop
are you going to take the very committal
decision of taking that knight
or just kind of go well my last move was
a mistake
[Laughter]
i'm not too proud to retreat the
position the bishop
and uh yeah definitely for a proud
person such as magnus i don't think he's
going to find it too comfortable to kind
of retreat the bishop
but it might be the best move that's
right and sometimes in chess
pride can be a bit of a sin sometimes
you just gotta think okay
i might have made a mistake but now i
just gotta correct that mistake take a
time out
and um i mean i think retreating here
it's
it's
not so natural um it just looks like
it's lost a move for black so
maybe we'll see a bishop for night trade
but magnus carson this is where he will
spend a bit of time and
wesley i mean this is a tip for everyone
at home as well in rapid chess just ask
your opponent questions set them small
traps
kind of give them a choice of three or
four moves which look roughly equal
make them spend that time doubting
themselves
and that's why wesley so is so good at
rapid chess
yeah i kind of have an expression
sometimes you know you've got to give
the
your opponent the ability to show their
strength and i mean in a really negative
way
[Laughter]
so yes and you know like bishop takes
bishop taking the pawn would be a
mistake
but you know it would be tempting to
someone who's greedy and goes yeah i
think i can get away with it
you might do it you never know what
people think up
yeah i love that when you guys let us
know that the pieces are talking
together
to themselves or to other pieces
i think wesley he was definitely talking
to that rook and that white rook in the
bottom corner there yeah
um he was saying how can i improve you
and that's why he saw this idea
um otherwise this it's just so hard to
give up a pawn in a roughly
kind of balanced position with queens
off the board it's so
so rare to kind of even see that idea
and he definitely put magnus in a long
thinking break there with that move
so a good move by wesley there is it
any possibility that with that move
maybe the game will oh wow
that one movie shouldn't do it
that was something we were not a big fan
of because suddenly and you can see
wesley's rook has activated itself and
you can see the bar
slightly shut up but it's not too
dramatic yeah i mean it's
it's not kind of a game-losing blunder
um it's not going to end the game
immediately but suddenly we see
also the bar agrees white is the one
with the advantage now it went from a
completely level position
um to suddenly white having this
beautiful rook um
in the black camp that white rook now
attacking a pawn as well
if you just compare that rook to how it
looked three moves ago
so sad and lonely in that corner um mine
has spent so much time thinking about
that move and he made that one move that
you said
instantly so magnus shouldn't now take
this pawn and he did
is he a little bit rusty in the start
here in range i was about to say he is
rusty but wesley so's last move was not
a good one
um okay it's it's fine but it just means
he's going for the draw he's just
eliminated the knights
yeah okay i think we're probably going
to see a repetition of moose
the rook is going to carry on checking
the king and yep
that's it he had a chance just to
put the pressure on magnus and he
decided not to go for it
i think a huge missed opportunity to
just show magnus whose boss
i mean wesley so he could have just used
that very active rook he had to
slowly massage him apply the pressure um
to show magnus okay you have to defend
i'm in control but wesley just went
straight for the draw
maybe he just wants to save energy it is
9am where he is
that's right and these two players now
have a long break before the next round
starting on top of the hour in
45 minutes or so magnus is sitting there
he's been looking very much
to the right in this game i'm i'm
wondering what he's looking at
maybe a beautiful view but he does want
to look over this
position the game ended in a draw after
um
only 33 well well 33 moves but they
played that very fast actually
they definitely did play very fast and
yes
wasn't quite it was one moment where it
got very exciting especially when
wesley asked magnus to take a decision
and magnus took a slightly inaccurate
one
so that was very very interesting but
then unfortunately the game just
completely fizzled out into a draw
and nothing could be done all right well
that that was uh
the first game that we followed in round
two of their things masters and
obviously
all the other games are still going on
and we will now follow the game
between levonaronian who played a draw
against magnus carlsen
in the first game um he's facing aneesh
giri the dutch
who in the first game played a door
against yon the pognyacci now david
jumping into the position is anyone
winning this one
wow um i don't think either side's
winning right now
but it is a crazy position so much has
happened wow
um i mean it's very hard to evaluate as
well i see that white king is under
attack on the left side there
black's king meanwhile is much safer
that being said white is actually
material ahead um maybe if we bring up
the analysis board just to get the hang
of some of the
key factors in the position we do see a
trade here as well so
this is the current position white king
is a bit open
um this black bishop very nicely placed
around that king
we have seen a trade of pawns as well um
the material imbalance though
we see here white has two rooks black
only has one that being said
it's a rook for bishop advantage so this
is kind of a two-point advantage
meanwhile black does have one extra pawn
so white is slightly ahead of material
but it's all going to come down to whose
king is safer
and we've seen we've seen a huge
development
um last move
a very surprising one he's ignored an
attack on this pawn in the middle
i thought he would have to defend that
he's ignored that he's trying to trap
this black bishop his last move
pushing this pawn up one square this
black bishop i said it was strong just a
moment ago
it's now actually trapped and this is so
hard to evaluate
basically i think he's playing for a uh
kind of playing a bit tricky here um
black could capture this pawn attacking
a rook here
attacking a rook and this happened
it's happening it's over the board oh
this is
sharp sharp stuff david and just as a
little bit of a trivia
where do you which opening do you think
this was
kaya what openly do you
yes we have a tweet from chess24 it says
geary's dedication to promoting his
chessable
night of course is very impressive and
there you can see
the results there on the bar certainly
agrees it's very impressive
that's right as kaia's favorite opening
is anishigiri's new favorite opening
i know i'm going to go and buy that
chessball course because my knowledge on
the night off is very shaky at best
i'm always a bit scared because the
night off it's such an aggressive
opening black
just wants to play for a counter attack
very early on in the game it's always
very imbalanced
crazy stuff happens so any attacking
players out there or any players who
like to attack the opponent's king
this i mean the night off is a great
weapon as black
and go check out anish geary's course
but meanwhile this position is
i mean it's just exploded into life we
chose the right moment to jump in
for sure and white's last move bringing
that knight back keeps the king nice and
protected
that knight also eyes up that black
bishop in the corner there that black
bishop on the left side
is completely trapped black might be
able to win one of the rooks
um for his bishop to win one of the
white rooks for his central bishop
but if he loses that piece in the corner
it will all be over and anish giri is
actually
leaning in and he only has one move here
actually
to avoid a huge disadvantage to
kind of stay in the game and it's not an
obvious one
maybe we can bring up the board just to
show anish giri
certainly not obvious at all absolutely
and uh yeah go for it david because
i can't wait to see what you're showing
us because wow yeah this is a wild
position this bishop is attacking two
rooks but at the moment it cannot take
either of them
because if it moves the black queen will
be undefended
behind it therefore black should move
his rook forward he should
use his rook to defend this queen also
white is sometimes threatening to check
the black king
and by pushing his rook forward if white
decides to give a check
the black king can just step forward so
kind of multi-purpose move but it's not
obvious at all for humans especially
anishigiri with less than two minutes on
this clock
and levon almost 16 minutes i was going
to say that yeah
look at the time trace for us it's just
absolutely unheard of you know
16 minutes i didn't even notice that
i was like girls so still so early in
the game no
this is razor sharp and uh yes
you know what guys i i think move 27 i
just have a feeling levon ironian he
might have actually studied this
position
before his exact position i mean 27
moves it sounds crazy to have
gone so deep um but maybe he's watched
anish giri's video course maybe he knows
what ish gary recommends or maybe he's
seen a game that anish has played before
and he's just predicted every single
move in advance so
i mean that would be fantastic homework
if that's true okay meanwhile anishgiri
has found the correct move the best move
for black there defending
the black queen with his rook um one
minute on the clock though against 16
minutes
yeah exactly this is just a serious time
deficit you know it really is because
it's still incredibly sharp there is so
many accurate moves that anish has to
find
and when the clock starts ticking down
we do know that the panic sets in
the hand starts getting happy and starts
trying to find these automatic moves
maybe there's even the danger that you
pre-move and you pre-move in the wrong
way
oh this is kind of all the factors of
online chess
and uh yeah but another one can just
relax
and work everything out definitely but i
mean
one fact obviously levon played
extremely fast here but
i mean anish also playing unusually slow
hair
that's right and that's that's just
because the position is so imbalanced
it's so wild and complicated it's not
kind of a traditional game like we saw
against
uh between wesley sir and magnus it's
not where you can just slowly improve
your pieces
um follow general rules like controlling
the sensor this one it's about
going for checkmate and counting the
pieces trying to calculate
three four five move variations so this
one is extremely complicated
um that's what makes me think that levon
aronian he's studied something similar
before at least
but anish giri yeah it's going to be a
battle against not just the clock not
just the position
um battle against levon iranian's
homework and i wouldn't be surprised to
see
levon move one of his rooks now he can
give a check with his rook we mentioned
that a bit earlier he could also that
look at the bottom corner there he's not
doing anything again he could just
bring it towards the center lots and
lots of choice for
iranian meanwhile that black bishop as
well it's trapped
in the corner of the board yeah that's
that's going to be playing on anish's
mind because if he lets the
initiative his attack lose momentum that
bishop
is going to get eaten and there's
nothing to do about that one
so yeah he has to i mean i i i for one
as white i would not be
the big cardinal sin here is if lavonne
looks at the clock time and goes
on the verge of winning and gets over
excited and starts playing quickly no
lavon
but you know these guys are super
experienced so he will just know that he
has to just
simply carry on maintaining the pressure
asking his opponent questions
and uh yeah i don't expect levon to play
rook check i expect something a little
less
committal less direct yeah and actually
this is one tip as well for everyone at
home
as someone myself who gets low on time
in every single game
what i want actually my opponents to do
is i want them to play
just as quickly as me i want them to put
pressure on me on the clock because that
shows that they're equally as nervous as
i am
that means i can kind of play on the
adrenaline but if they stop if they stop
for five
ten minutes just sit there calmly take a
long think
um then suddenly the adrenaline drains
out of me i lose my rhythm and it's just
hard to stay focused when you're in this
state of kind of increased
sensitivity so yeah i think levon
aronian
as ivanka mentioned he should spend five
six minutes here just
working things out being a hundred
percent sure he knows what's going on he
shouldn't worry about an issue of his
clock time
no he shouldn't hate it shouldn't that
affect his decision making too much and
especially because he knows that he can
like
now is the time to kind of steady the
ship
keep everything calm and then use that
long-term problem of that
trapped black bishop and everything will
be great
that's right i think he should just um
sort out the attack
um on his rooks so move one of the rooks
right now um
and long term that bishop will drop off
that black bishop so it's just about not
rushing both on the clock and the
position actually
isn't it hard i heard some players say
this before that
when your opponent has little time on
the clock it's easy to start rushing
yourself
because the opponent plays fast moves
and then maybe even if you have a lot of
time you get sort of fooled into playing
fast
yeah you just you just get caught up in
the adrenaline you know they're playing
fast and you're like oh
yes let's let's speed up and and before
you know it
you're also playing as quickly as they
are and uh
you then finish the game in amount of
speed and everyone turns to you and says
why didn't you slow down yeah well
i didn't think about it too much maybe
it's easier in online chess than when
you don't have that over
the board everything is intense it's so
much intensified in online chess you
know whatever you feel over the board
it's multiplied by ten
because you can always see that clock
ticking down and you're there ready with
a mouse and you're ready to make that
move
and somehow it's just so much more
intense than it is over the board
yeah that's right and levon we saw him
lean back just adjust himself
he's fully aware of these kind of uh
phenomenons of all the psychology of
time trouble
maybe you should have sort of these
post-its on your screen
to sort of remind you of uh take your
time
i'll tell you what the best advice sit
on your hands
to the children if you don't do the
trigger happy mouse yeah exactly sit on
your hands and just
yes and then look around the board and
then you make your move
but yeah and then you have to probably
do exactly the same thing with your
mouse just like
not have your hand over the mouse just
kind of
what would be on your opposite david
just play better moves
i'd have hundreds of post-its i'm not
sure the players are they allowed that
though would that be
kind of external help i know that we we
crack down on the uh
cheating we have cameras all around
imagine if we have these cameras and we
just see post-it notes yeah that's true
you can do it you can do it if you're
being cute yeah
well i wouldn't be cheating you're
allowed to motivate yourself true yeah
actually there was a famous case a few
years ago in the american championship
wesley so he was
writing notes to himself on the back of
his scoresheet where we kind of notate
the moves
and that isn't allowed actually and um
flurry of moves meanwhile we have seen a
lot of moves um so
levon aronian he decided in that
position he went with
your advice actually ivanka um yeah the
bar swung
all the way all the way across to white
side um so he took ivanka's advice he
moved this rook which was attacked in
the corner
um he just swung that across and anish
geary
decided okay this tension along this
line is just too much
he took the rook with his bishop we see
a lot of trades the queen's left the
board
and actually if we do a count here white
has a rook and knight
normally the rook's worth five um the
knight were three against
two bishops the bishops worth three
points each more importantly though the
black bishop is trapped
and in this position um we did see
um a couple more moves we saw okay
the black king jumped forward and white
just moved across with his rook so now
he's
possibly eyeing up a check against the
black king
more importantly though i think he has a
sneaky idea in mind he wants to bring
his rook across
and try and eventually trap this bishop
the reason white cannot capture this
bishop at the moment
is because the knight is actually pinned
that means that the knight cannot move
because the king is behind it
yeah very tense situation i think white
is doing fantastically well but
still some chances um yeah still some
chances i mean
the only chance that i can see is that
that's that's what i was thinking
just get going with the pawns on the
right side
try to push them try to create some kind
of activity there
just to keep that white work at bay
because
like you said if that white rogue
manages to munch on this bishop and
there's
no uh okay yeah and actually anisha is
that just a blunder
yeah anish he pushed a pawn forward but
that pawn was just taken by a white rook
um and anish actually i mean it was
almost imperceptible but he just widened
his eyes as if he hadn't even seen that
move as possible
maybe he was just focusing so much on
that left side of the board that he just
forgot that levon could
capture his pawn and now he's been
i mean he's lost his best chance by
pushing those pawns forward
um he should maybe have kept those moves
for a bit later on but now that pawn's
disappeared white's rook is going behind
again
white's rook is deep in the enemy
territory white's rook is going to swing
across
and try and capture that black bishop
that's trapped that has been trapped for
so long
um it's looking terminal for any fury
and yes
you see the stockfish evaluation of the
bar the computer there it does think
that white is winning yeah and you can
see uh anish
has just moved the bishop to try to
prevent white's plan but i think it is a
little bit futile
because the ruike that bishop can only
cover light squares and the
rook of course is so flexible can move
on the dark squares and uh
yeah and we see levon aronian push upon
there um
maybe we bring up the board we can see
one trap that anish kerry set up
on the last move he played a very sneaky
one if levon was short of time he might
have
pre-moved so he might have made this
move in advance to come and try and
capture this bishop
this is something that i wanted to do
last move it was what i was aiming for
but black's last move
very sneaky it keeps an eye on this
square so preventing levon's idea
so if levon if he panicked if he kind of
just rushed a bit he would have lost his
rook instead he just pushes his pawn
slightly closer to the promotion square
if it gets to the end of the ward it
will become a new queen
um and i think actually anishkiri he's
just stuck there's not much he can do
this bishop trapped he's essentially
playing without a piece
um there's not too much hope here
unfortunately not too much time 19
seconds for an east geary it is
one road in the move though he's just
moving under 10 minutes
such yeah and then you can see it the
rook is traveling on the dark squares
that's right and it's got his eyes as
david says on that poor trapped bishop
that uh i cannot make a move
yeah that black bishop it's doomed um he
just has to find a way to distract white
but it's too slow black's pawns are not
close enough okay
and yeah you can see that uh anish has
desperately tried to give up a pawn and
now the black bishop is out but it's
calm at a cost
i think all of uh black's queen's black
pawns on the left side have disappeared
and then now they just those buttons are
just gonna start
queening that's right white can at his
leisure start pushing that pawn on the
left side of the board
white's pawn on the right as well is
very close to promotion so
um it's just a matter of technique now
lavon he moves his king
out of the eye line of that black bishop
in the center of the board um
very very calm played by roman he took
your advice ivanka he
slowed down at the key moment he just
worked out everything in advance and
um he's not taking any risks he's kept
everything nice and protected
and yes this one is not going to last
for too much longer and you should use
bishops
normally we talk about the bishop pair
as being great but they're just not
um equipped now to fight against the
white's rook and all those pawns
oh yeah exactly and those pawns once we
start pushing them they kind of have
they're not the most valuable piece but
they do have a special trump card that
when they reach the edge of the board
well basically they can turn into a rook
a bishop or knight or even a queen
and that's it it'll be game over and of
course you really want them to promote
to a queen
and it is game over the von neuronian
yeah has won this game against
anish kiwi and uh well anish
he is a very good loser he he always
takes it very well and he looks over the
game and then he he moves on but i have
to say levon ronian
he's just looking fierce today yeah i
mean
incredible form um not just in this game
also the last game against magnus he
played the first
10 15 moves so quickly and this one i
mean he
pretty much we barely blinked and he
played the first 27 moves so
um he's come prepared probably over
christmas he was just in study mode
he'd activated killer mode and um yeah
anish giri
sometimes you just got to hold your
hands up and say okay the opponent
played well not much you can do yes
do you think um an ishkiri he got off to
such a good start we remember in the
first tournament in the skilling open he
was the leader
before for the last day of preliminaries
what's happening to him today here it's
not
looking a little bit shaky yeah slightly
looking shaky but you do have to
remember it is
early days we're still two two games in
and
uh yeah we still have nine more rounds
to play for
and these are in very important rounds
because of course
after day three of the 11th game has
been played
then the top eight will go through onto
the knockout stages and you do have to
remember
it is 12 players this time in the air
things masters
which means that it's not as cutthroat
as the skinning open where 50
of the players left it's only four
players so you just have to avoid doing
a bad score and everything's okay
um and well so much fun with lavon
aronian though
one of the players that we really love
he's such a character in the chess world
david and he's just getting off to a
great start here
that's right and we we know that his
biggest cheerlead cheerleader is his dog
in the room with him um i wonder if
we'll see pawnchick later but
um levon aronian yeah when he's in form
and actually he brought his form at the
right moments
um last time in the skilling open he
struggled on the first couple of days
but he um he powered through with some
wins on the final day of the
preliminaries here he's started much
better he's already had
the world champion magnus carson he's
neutralized him he's got that game out
of the way and now he's beaten anishiri
one of his biggest rivals for
qualification
all right well uh only two games
finished we we followed both the games i
finished in round two
uh levon aronian who beat on each geary
and was they saw in minus carlson who
played the draw so now we're heading
into game
number three between two of the wild
cards coming into this tournament kansai
krishna and donald
dubomb david i see the bar is just
completely in the center here just
saying this is a complete
i think we might be unlucky here that
we've chosen a third game
that's going to finish on the spot
except the players have just repeated
the moves
we didn't even get to talk about one
single move here
we can talk about one move essentially
white gave lots of checks with the
with the queen and black's king had no
shelter it couldn't hide
so we call it perpetual check you could
check forever and that's why the
game is declared a draw after three
repetitions of the position
um essentially in queen end games it's
all about checks
if your king can find safety then you
might have some chances to win but
neither side's king is safe here
and the game is just naturally yeah
there was just no escape route for that
king you know because you need to
start falling out it's not so much about
calculation
and working out the possibilities you
just have to spot that route and go okay
the king is headed in that direction and
it's safe to do dash there
and here there's just no way to escape
the checks yeah that's right
just our luck you just got a crash
course in and
a perpetual check there yes straight
into the perpetual check-in
nice to get to know some of these new
players that we have in this tournament
hari krishna
um and donald dubose you i mean
do these players have a chance here uh
among the top players
i think definitely um i've played hare
krishna many times
actually i one of the longest games in
chess history was played between me and
him last year we played 236 moves
each um in that game i think it was like
the fourth longest maybe
in history but uh yeah he's a fighting
player that ended in a draw
i tried my best to win but uh not quite
close enough so he's a fighter basically
he doesn't want to settle for those
draws a draw like this one
would disappoint him slightly with wyatt
against one of the uh kind of one of his
direct rivals
meanwhile dubov he's just
i'm i'm one of his biggest fans he
played just last week
um in the russian championship he played
one of the best games i've ever seen
um he defeated sergey karyakin the
minister of defense
former world championship challenger
with a series of spectacular sacrifices
on his day dubov
um yeah he could beat anyone and i
wouldn't be surprised to see him qualify
sometimes he's maybe not as consistent
as his rivals um
so if he's in form um yeah
i mean these guys are seriously good
kyle you know duboff was also world
rapid champion
and then you have penta harry krishna
who was in the top 10 in the world
you underestimate these guys at your
peril and they both thrive in
complicated positions and this is just
what you need for this
type of fast chess so definitely they
have so much to play for so i would
definitely
not discount these guys yeah definitely
and i think
yeah anyone who underestimates them will
get punished yeah and and
dubo also he's only in the start of his
20s no he's not very old but
is is he one of the coaches for magnus
carlsen as well or one of the seconds
that's right i mean wow imagine being 24
years old you've
been part of a world champions coaching
team you've won the world rapid
championship
it's pretty impressive it's very
impressive yeah what i like about duboff
is that he looked at the style of all
the greats and he was like
yeah they're great they're but i'm not
going to emulate them i'm going to make
my
own style and you know you can see in
his chest he's aggressive
he's creative he's kind of like a
combination of all the previous world
champions and it's just fantastic to
watch
fantastic to watch and talking about
watching
in an online forum that the champions
chess tour is we're so entertained
with watching the players on their
webcams now now we and when we see them
on over the board tournaments
they're very like poker faced and
they're very subtle but in these
tournaments we've seen
punching of webcams and we've seen just
yawning and we've seen screaming and
we've seen everything now what does the
player think about
being shown on the webcams look at this
i make a point of just not looking at my
opponent so i only have my own webcam
when i play and i can always look at
myself just to make sure i'm in frame
and i'm
looking as beautiful as always if you
play heater or magnus
it's good from time to time to look at
their faith these guys they have a
phd in acting for me it's nothing
unusual it's nakamura's shaking his head
after move one is normal after move 50
is normal
he tries to give away so many fake tales
i just decided that i will not try to
get anything from that
these like hikaru does or like these you
know and all these things that they do
with magnus and all these
theatrical performances they they have
become incredibly good at
personally i think i'm a bit of an open
book but i don't really care like
i'm usually not satisfied with my play
anyway they start shaking head when they
blunder only when
um the short opponent also sees it they
will never
do that when they blunder something
tricky so you shouldn't be fooled i
rarely show
emotions anyway when i'm playing even
even on the webcam i usually turn it off
i only turn it on when i'm hundred
percent sure i'm winning
and i just want to see you know how
he's suffering
[Music]
okay so we haven't followed alexander
grishard uh too much so far but
you know he seems so russian just
watching his opening suffer
we know now that he's a sadist he likes
to see them
um yeah i mean it's so fascinating to
see the differences between online and
over-the-board chess and um yeah i know
i love studying my police expression
over the board
i know i'd have that web come up but
sometimes it's better not to get
distracted i guess just focus on the
moves
how big part of an online tournament is
actually these
webcams for the players do you think
ivanka i think it's a big thing you know
it's certainly something that i think
you should be mindful of it's so easy
though to forget that it's there because
you have the board exploded up and then
you have the webcam
somewhere else but i think it is very
very important just to kind of have a
look
especially when it comes to a critical
decision that you've kind of posed with
the opponent
and then you can kind of get gauge
whether they've been surprised
whether this was expected whether they
you know are slightly
off-put by the whole thing and then you
can kind of assess and then you can kind
of feel like
getting the upper hand and it's also
important when their clock is ticking to
see whether they're panicking
and didn't we actually talk about this
in the first game between magnus carlsen
and levon aronian
when magnus had the possibility to
actually win the game to find that move
to take the rook
you said if he would be watching levon
arunian's webcam then he would see that
lavone would be shaking his head
exactly exactly he gave the game away
didn't he lavonne aronian both santa he
lost his poker face he lost the pokey
there was no poker face he immediately
went oh no
look what's happened there and uh yeah
of course there was a one-move blunder
but magnus didn't spot it
yeah i'm sorry we'll go ahead i was
gonna say the danger is with the double
bluffing sometimes the opponent might
shake the head but nothing's wrong
so you might lose two or three minutes
on the clock trying to figure out like
how did they blunder i didn't see it
so um i think a lot of mind games yeah i
think that's one of the
most common common over-the-board things
that you pull as a child
you know you blunder a queen but you're
threatening checkmates
[Laughter]
and then you know when that queen comes
off and they're like oh i'm very sorry
you know i've lost a little girl
and you kind of go checkmate
actually when we see over the board
tournaments there is a lot of like
it is a gentleman sports you're supposed
to be very respectful of your opener
you're not supposed to
you know make noises or or or be
disrespectful is it a little bit more
allowed
in online chess to just scream a little
bit if you want to or just
show a little bit more emotion yeah i
think anything goes in
online chess pretty much and that's one
of the beauties of it it's kind of we
see the players
uncensored no holds barred just being
their true selves and the personalities
come
out a lot more yeah definitely i agree
that you know
with with online chess you can kind of
mute your microphone in some situations
and so
and so no so you can basically like
hover your piece
over hover your mouth oh mouth
mouth mouth hover your mouth
over the piece that you think you should
move and then move it away you would
never be allowed to do that
and you can even give yourself pep talks
like come on you can do this okay maybe
you messed up but let's get going
and and also to use it as a
psychological or tactical or
or give away like magnus said he he
doesn't like to watch nakamura because
he gives away fake tales he wants to
maybe maybe look like he's losing or but
instead maybe he's feeling very
confident
yeah i mean especially for the players
who may be newer to the field like harry
krishna like do both they might not know
their opponents as well
so it's harder to read the tells i mean
for magnus and
nakamura who played each other hundreds
maybe thousands of times
um yeah i'm sure he's seen it all before
so he doesn't need to look at the camera
all right well so much fun with these
online tournaments watching the players
webcams and we do know that they do like
to watch each other as well
from time to time now um we do have two
excellent chess players in the studio
helping us understand
everything uh me myself i'm quite new to
chess i'm not very experienced with
playing but i'm trying to learn
and during the air things monster we
will let you guys
follow as i try to learn a little bit
more in chess and this is
episode one and kaya tries to learn
chess
[Music]
yay all right easy start next one
okay i need to do better in this next
one how about this one
i'll try that one no oh the other side
ah and now mr schaible would say
you resign now and he keeps moving give
up
give up okay this was quite hard this
was quite hard i have to say and i
definitely feel the time pressure i got
the congratulations i think i learned
something today as well
yay
all right adjustable challenge how did i
do you michael yeah you did great
slightly you should then he could have
done the trick but you want to go oh
look i planted a queen
i sometimes do these these challenges
and and
you know i'm looking i'm looking i'm
looking and i feel stressed that i have
to find the move and when i suddenly see
it
i'm like oh why did i not see that right
away you should just have our voices
in your head if you'd remembered
ivanka's phrase the octo knight knights
in the middle of the board
bringing that knight to the center so
close they were hard positions though to
be fair
well i'm learning and it's interesting
to learning and um
chess is a lot of fun it is a lot of fun
to be playing now um
we have three seen three games finished
in round two
of uh um they're things monsters and uh
uh we did follow wesley and magnus
carlson in the first game
uh david it it ended in a draw there but
but
um wesley had one interesting move that
we talked about maybe we can
actually go through that game and see
what happened when
when he sort of offered his pawn there
but it was a great thought behind it
that's right yeah sure um we did see
kind of a very timid opening from wesley
so maybe not the most ambitious opening
he's
ever played in his life but the critical
moment came when he pushed a pawn
forward
to attack this black bishop this pawn
now
eyeing up the bishop asking a difficult
question what do you do magnus with that
bishop and magnus
spent a long time on the clock here five
six minutes he was just debating does he
capture this night does he take this
pawn
looks like that one might be um kind of
for free right now or does he retreat
his bishop
but the problem is his bishop just came
from there
so after a long long thing magnus
decided
it's time to capture this pawn we didn't
like that decision here in the studio i
know
i was very critical of it um ivanka
wasn't a huge fan either
this allowed the white rook which was
previously dormant
in the corner here this white rook was
doing nothing at all didn't have any
good squares any open lines
suddenly it swung across to attack this
black bishop
and this bishop when it did move wesley
so captured a pawn
so this white rook has gone from being a
terrible piece a very passive piece
not taking part in the game to being the
best piece on the board attacking this
pawn
very active in the enemy camp we did see
a trade of bishops
and after magnus carson dropped his rook
back to defend this pawn
we can compare the pieces white's rook
is very active it's doing an attacking
job
attacking the pawn black's piece we
would call that passive because it's
doing a defensive job
and here i think wesley had a few very
nice options
what i probably would have done is i'd
have retreated my rook slightly
just attacking this undefended pawn in
the center of the board you always want
to look for pieces that don't have any
protection
um for example if black decides to spend
a move protecting it
he could again start attacking things
this knight is the one on defender this
time
the knight might have to retreat um for
example to go back
and suddenly white can start jumping
forward suddenly the white knight the
white rook
they're they're very very nicely placed
meanwhile black's pieces
they're kind of cramped this rook is
stuck doing a very sad defensive job i
think this would have given wesley so
great
winning chances still maybe magnus
carlsen could have held this
if he was accurate but he could have
tested the world champion instead
going back a few moves he just pretty
much silently offered a draw he just
allowed the knights to be exchanged he
offered a trade here
and after black captured this pawn there
was nothing left to do
both sides have a rook both sides have
four pawns but more importantly there's
no way to check mate no way to
get a pawn to the end of the board and
make a promotion so
um after a few more checks we did see a
repetition of the position and the game
was a draw
missed opportunity missed opportunity
and magnus usually gets very
annoyed when his opponents sort of
doesn't push for the win when you see
they actually have an opportunity for it
that's right i think magnus would have
been slightly annoyed but slightly
relieved
he would have been thinking okay i might
have had to defend that position for the
next 20 minutes
um for the next 50 moves but instead he
got away with a quick escape
and he gets a long break before the next
game exactly yeah it's like this magnus
effect i think
against if wesley had been playing
myself or
perhaps even yourself i think he would
never ever have chosen that night move
you'd want to crush yourself exactly he
didn't want to play you want to make
sure that
actually hey we should prove that we
know how to draw
but it's like some magnus kind of effect
like oh you know some magic powder gets
thrown into the air
and versus like okay draw and
slightly disappointing but again magnus
is very very lucky
and you mentioned it also david the game
was over after
uh 20 minutes or something like that was
very fast so
they do now have a lot of time it's it's
a little bit less than 10 minutes until
the third round starts
how are they spending the time when they
have so much time in between games
yeah when they have so much time it's
very important just to relax
just to refocus the mind and just look
ahead because you have
two more games to play and yeah you just
have to be in the best
mental shape there and you can't be
dwelling on the fact that maybe you
missed an opportunity you just have to
okay
let's take pause recharge will they
actually
maybe leave the house david go for a
walk get some fresh air
or will they just stay in the mode do
you think and maybe eat something and
look at the next games
yeah and actually in the last tournament
we see a lot of players we saw a lot of
players just sitting at the computer
analyzing their previous games maybe
studying some of their next opponents
previous games just to try and um
predict the opening opening stages i
think snacks are always good
i always have a bit of chocolate maybe a
banana there just to have that little
boost of energy
fresh air is always good as well but
chess players we forget we get so
carried away right
for the next game um we want to feel 100
prepared 100
ready sometimes we forget to prioritize
these things we just get
too carried away with the board and uh
especially with the computer analysis
it's so tempting to just sit there
yes um a walk in the park is good but
yeah i think the players they'll be
sitting there at the computer
all right well ladies and gentlemen
round two of their things monsters
have finished all games are done and
these are
the results wesley sew magnus crawls and
they play the draw
and um maximum vaccine um
and hikaru nakamura also played a rohi
car won that first game we know
now in the game the all-russian game
between napogniachi and
grisha krishak won that game wow
you guys said napoleon she might be the
favorites yes maybe but you know you
cannot discount
alissa alexander christchurch you know
he has been world blitz champion
three times he is such a dangerous
player
and yep you can't discount him and as
you can see
he defeated ian and pogbachy and uh
as we know levon ronyan also beat anish
uh geary we followed that game mines
carlson wesley saw that was the draw
as we talked about teemo rajabo he got a
win against
uh david anton maybe not the biggest
surprise david anton is an underdog in
this tournament david
yeah that's right david anton he is an
underdog but he did get voted back in by
the public because he did so well in
that skilling open
especially on that first day he caused a
few upsets he beat some very strong
players
nepalniacci and others um i think maybe
in this pool of sharks where everyone is
out for blood
maybe he just needed that quick start to
give him a bit of a confidence boost now
they'll all be
circling they'll all be trying to pounce
um i'm hoping he can bounce back today
i'm hoping that too but you know i have
to say roger both was probably
feeling extra happy because he of course
lost to david anton
in the skinning open in the preliminary
section there so it'll be extra sweet
yes he won and we do now have three
players on the top of the table with
one and a half points nakamura levon
aronian
and team roger were really three of the
big favorites david
yeah that's right but it will be
interesting to see their strategy for
the next few rounds do they settle for
what they've got do they just play solid
um the risk is that if one or two losses
and they could just
they could plummet in the rankings or do
they try and push on do they use that
momentum and try and secure their place
before the final day in the knockout
stages all right well
one player that really needs to fight
back after loss in the second round
is one of our favorite players in east
geary such a
wonderful chess player such a fun guy
and
i'm going to show you something now that
it's very interesting actually because
because uh
anish giri he's got a love for
his wife obviously but he's got a love
for one more thing take a look
at this
the love for the french defense david
that's right i mean
i'm not a big fan of the opening but i'm
a huge fan of that video and um
and anisha's wife as well sophiko
guramish really such a strong player
um i mean imagine sitting in on some of
their analysis sessions just studying
these openings and
he does have that video course on
chesapeal which i hugely recommend
checking out
yeah and of course she also has a lot of
chess videos on
chess 24 she's known as miss tactics on
that site so it's absolutely brilliant
and i just love that video as well when
it came out i was like wow
it is another level yeah it is beautiful
now
we are doing a quiz today and we will do
a quiz every day during their things
masters the quiz
of today is the question we're asking is
who is the reigning official random
world champion
ivanka such an interesting question and
and how do people answer this to
contend for the price of the the premium
membership one-year premium membership
on chesterton
yes you have to submit your answer
with the hashtag chesschamps
and yes do we have any prizes for
guessing
we do have a chess for 24 premiership
oh let me start again the prize of this
quiz
is a one years premium membership on a
chess
24. do we know the answer here i know
the answer
yes you know we all know the answer i
think i know the answer too but
we should maybe tell people what fish
are random maybe they don't actually
know what fish around them is what is
fisher random
yeah fisher random is a special variant
of
chess which was recently actually
introduced by the feeder
which is the regulation board as an
official variant of chess
and what it is is that uh you start with
the pieces all jumbled up the only rule
is that the king
must be between the two rooks and then
there's like a drawing of lots where
they go well knight goes
the first spot where the rook should be
and then everything is completely messed
up and you get the most
random well hence the name yeah
positions
and it's such a strange game because you
can have a situation where your queen is
in the corner
and every single piece is just like whoa
what is that and it's just incredibly
uh unusual all right and one player is
the world champion in in the fisher
random so
if you know the answer just uh tweet us
using the hashtag chesschamps
and you will be contenting for the prize
of one year premium membership on just
24.
now we are looking forward to the next
round it will start in
three minutes and uh
we've seen a lot of draw so far david do
you think players now will be
feeling okay we've started i'm ready i'm
gonna go for some wins now
yeah i'm pretty sure the first couple of
rounds from my own experience there's
always a bit of nerves
right you don't want to kind of be
eliminated from the running by losing a
couple of games at the beginning your
confidence will be shattered
some of the players who have made a
couple of draws um they will be looking
for their right moment to pounce to
strike
and i think as the days go on players
get more tired as well there will be
more mistakes
more decisive results yeah all right now
these are
uh let's take a look at the six games
that we will see now in round three game
one
daniel dubo he's going to face maxim
bashir lagrave
next game will be between david anton
and
pantala hari krishna third game magnus
carlsen facing timor
rajabov and then we have alexander
grisham who won his last game
he's now going to face levon ronyan who
also won okay
ivanka who's the favorite in this game
now wow i definitely would be
both guys feeling the momentum but i
still have to edge it with lavonne
aronian you know he has got one and a
half points out of two
and he had such a great start holding
that game against magnus carlsen and of
course
beating anishigiri with using
virtually no time on the clock that has
to feel good so yeah
levon heronia all right next game is
going to be between
ikaru nakamura who's looking super
confident today he's facing against
wesley because wesley's very solid and
perhaps he just wants to get
wesley out of his comfort zone that's
right especially with black
um actually we've seen it with white
already this tournament wesley so
sometimes happy to just make drawers to
be solid
um and here with the black pieces i
think wesley will be
relatively happy with the outcome um as
we see anishikuri
have a bit of a think here white
essentially needs to decide
how and when to open up the position um
wow that last move is very mysterious i
did not expect it if we bring up the
analysis board
we can see a couple of ideas for both
sides white's last move
very unexpected uh for me is to play his
queen across here
and i just have a feeling this is
probably as you mentioned ivanka it is
home preparation this is an idea
anishgiri has prepared before
he brought this queen across it looks
like a very odd square blocking in this
rook
this white rook now has nowhere to go
it's completely blocked in but white has
two ideas he wants to bring his queen
forward
and create a kind of battery along this
diagonal with the queen and bishop using
teamwork
ganging up together against a weak black
pawn the other idea is to activate the
other rook
maybe lining up this rook with the black
queen i think black meanwhile has to
decide
how is he going to develop his pieces
black's bishop at the moment is a bit
blocked his rooks
need to be connected to each other this
one is going to liven up but
promising start lots of tension still at
the moment okay
wesley so gaining space in the center
there with a pawn
so yes this has been seen before this
idea has been seen before but only once
so we're definitely in anishiri's
preparation
and now after wesley's response we are
actually completely
new territory wow yeah um
i mean i'm learning something just as
much as
the people at home this is something
i've never seen before it's
very very rare um both sides had lots
and lots of
um kind of uh options in the earlier
stages
and now with anishigiri's last move just
pushing a pawn up it looks very modest
but he's
he's just preparing to push his other
central pawn two squares forward
um the white pawn there that usually
starts in front of the queen he's going
to explode the center and he
he's arguing that white is more ready
than black and
wesley so decides to push forward uh
he's pushing another pawn forward
wesley so is taking as much space as he
can we talk about space
if you if your pawns are further forward
you just have more space to maneuver
your pieces
you have more squares more scope to move
your pieces behind those pawns so
wesley he's pushing his pawns forward
first with black his pieces will come
after
meanwhile anish geary he has to justify
the reason for that kind of
slightly strange queen move just to
justify um allowing black to gain all
this space
yeah but it's very committal you know
this is the thing with porn moves
that you can't take them back and yes
that
it's true it's gained a lot of space but
i also think it's a little bit risky
because if it goes wrong well that's it
you know he's
too many weaknesses around the king and
no king wants to be we're surrounded by
empty space
and you can see like anish it's very
calm he just
ignored this kind of space it's like
okay i'm gonna play on the left side of
the board
no big deal yeah that's right um you do
touch on a key point there actually when
i first started the game
when i was a beginner i used to just
push all my pawns forward
but then it took me a long long time to
realize but pawns they're the only piece
that don't move backwards therefore they
do create weaknesses
behind them um sometimes you want pawns
covering squares
um especially weak squares you don't
want your pieces tied down to them
that being said i do like wesley so's
push of those pawns now he's just
brought his other bishop out black's
rooks are now connected all of black's
pieces
they're on very nice active squares um
i think black will next bring the rooks
towards the center anish he just needs
to open things up
white at the moment is camped in his
first three ranks that means the white
he definitely needs to take action
quickly you can't just slowly
sit there and let your opponent
suffocate you by pushing everything
forward yeah
you kind of have to think of these
positions like a spring you know okay
yes you're cramped for a while but then
you know you're looking for a way to
release it and they have to make that
break to explode open and i think we're
seeing
stage one being implemented there the
queen and the bishop have aligned
themselves on that
beautiful long diagonal that's right and
we mentioned a couple of plans earlier
on white has actually used both of those
plans
while he's pushed his rook across and
he's lined up his queen and
dark square bishop along the same
diagonal white was eyeing up one of
black's central pawns there therefore
black does defend that central pawn with
his bishop black's bishops
very nice in the center of the board um
yeah i think this one is still in the
balance as you ivanka mentions it's like
a spring white is so flat
so so flexible he will jump forward at
some point it's just about whether
wesley so
as black is ready for those developments
ready for some action
um to happen all right well we do know
that anish geary needs to strike back
after losing
in the last round against levon aronia
and wesley so he just he seems very
confident and he also said that going
into
this tournament after winning the last
one he's played so much online chess
over the last year
he's gotten very confident with it and
he's also said that you know
starting out the year he didn't even
have a nice like
computer mouse and he only had like a
very small laptop
he bought a big screen he's really
getting into this online format isn't he
yeah absolutely and you can see you know
with his big success at the skilling
open it's kind of reaped its rewards
he's definitely into it and he's has
such a beautiful style
so natural he knows where to put his
pieces
and it just really suits the online game
it's just the only thing with wesley is
that uh he's a little bit too pragmatic
for his own good
you know when you saw that against
magnus carlsen he could have played on
pushed magnus a little bit harder and he
chose not to
so yeah we will see but definitely i
love seeing wesley play
it's beautiful that's right i mean both
of these players actually they
both rarely ever lose um it's just
because
they just have such a nice fluid style
all of their pieces you never see
either of them especially wesley
actually you never see them with a bad
piece on the board they talk to their
pieces they centralize everything they
coordinate them
keep everything nicely guarded and
yeah i mean especially with wesley as
well he just never blunders he sees
everything the only way to beat him is
to slowly slowly accumulate lots of
strategic edges and then
hope that eventually that's enough um
but he's very tenacious and
anishigiri as well he does draw a lot of
games traditionally
but lately he's been a bit more
ambitious a bit more aggressive and
this opening shows that despite the
white knight retreating
that is kind of an aggressive move that
knight will jump forward a bit later on
and also the bishop the white bishop in
front of white's king there it's now
opened up
that diagonal that bishop's scope has
improved its line of vision
yeah yeah we see the bar it's just
completely in the middle
saying this is completely a draw right
now uh
maybe you could show us on the
analyzer's board i mean do they have any
possibilities to
to sort of push for the win yeah what
what should they do here
to be able to definitely there okay the
bar says it's in the middle but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's a draw it
just
means that the position is equal and
even being equal
doesn't necessarily mean that the
position is in fact just equal
because you can still have plenty to
play for there's still the possibility
of going wrong
and then you know on the flip side you
also have positions where there's like
nothing can go wrong and this i'm afraid
is going to be
one of those positions where absolutely
everything will be
there to play for that's right there's
so much tension and at the moment
the one thing i like about white's
pieces are these bishops this bishop
just has so much scope on a long
diagonal this is actually the longest
diagonal
um in chess you want your bishops on
these very
very nice uh lines bishops also long
range pieces
and as well white's queen and bishop
lined up together um black's last move
bringing his rook towards the center we
mentioned wesley so he never forgets any
piece he's improved his worst place
piece
i think it's time for anishigiri to
decide does he
go for something a bit controversial
does he capture this knight
to weaken um the central pawn instead he
just pushes forward oh look at the bar
that last move i don't like it at all we
said that giri needs to push forward
now this pawn it i mean it's advanced
one square so it should be on a better
square but i think he's actually worse
than this pawn
it's eyed up by the black rook and now
white's knight i thought it wanted to
jump forward a bit later on
now it's completely passive it's tied
down to the defense of this pawn
we said knights on the edge fall off the
hedge knights on the rim are dim
this white knight it only controls four
squares rather than the traditional
eight
it's very badly placed and i think it's
time for wesley so
to exchange off this beautiful bishop um
that we were talking about this white
bishop
it's also the best defender of white's
king right now so wesley so
could exchange that off we see stockfish
disagrees with me slightly but it also
wants to
go for the same idea it wants to attack
the white king yeah
and now i i think that we're going to
see your plan put into operation because
if we bear in the mind
wesley's last move which was
centralizing the rook it's
getting that exchange lined up and it's
such a classical kind of
kind of a maneuver that you exchange off
this
bishop because it weakens the king and
you remember what we said about like the
king
having lots of squares around it being
super uncomfortable you always have to
worry about king in that kind of
situation
and one thing that really worries me is
that the queen
is on the left side of the board the
white king is on the right side of the
board
[Laughter]
not happy there and you have to combine
that with white's lack of space
yes i think something has gone wrong
furnish yeah
the last two moves um in conjunction
with each other
i don't think they're very consistent um
and there we see okay wesley he has
followed
um the i mean he's chosen the line that
uh the move that i wanted him to play
he's just trying to exchange off one of
white's better pieces that bishop in
front of white's king
just white pieces they're all in the
first three ranks they're so cramped
what is that white rook doing for
example in the corner there on the
bottom left corner it's just doing
nothing right now um so
it will become a race can wesley so
attack white's king before white gets
organized
yeah yes but well we have it david
thinks yes
i think yes well what do you at home
think you know join in the fun join in
the conversation
and answer the question do you think
wesley will be able to punish
annie's niche's passive play well if you
think something
please get involved and by you can do
this by tweeting us by using the hashtag
chesschamps okay uh interesting move
here we see the bar shift
uh even more over to wesley's soul side
with with anisha's pawn move
that's right and anish i think he was
getting a bit desperate here he's just
trying to distract
black from a potential attack on the
right side so anish he pushed a pawn on
the left there
he's trying to open things up for those
white rooks which at the moment are just
doing absolutely nothing
we do see the bishops leave the board in
the meantime and wesley
he has options he can just allow a trade
of one set of pawns on that left side
but sooner or later he should just start
pushing those pawns towards the white
king
black's pawns in the center there very
nicely placed they'll be even stronger
if they push forward
lots and lots of options for wesley so i
think i think there's no right or wrong
answer yeah i think he's got a lot
you think if you were playing black
would you just go immediately for the
kill
because i would you would i would i
would
pick up my pawn and i would start trying
to go for an attack immediately
yeah that's right and uh maybe if we
bring up the board just to see how he
might attack how wesley so might attack
um i think ivanka is a big fan of just
pushing this pawn forward trying to open
up a line to
for the black rook towards the white
king if if a pawn gets
if a pawn gets further down a pawn on
this kind of square
is always going to be checkmating ideas
against the white king even if it
involves the sacrifice
maybe wesley so he doesn't like to take
too many risks maybe he'll deal with
this tension first maybe he'll just
capture a pawn
um white would attack the rook maybe
he'll just move this rook
and um i think wesley he doesn't need to
rush even his position is that good
whether he goes directly for the king or
that he doesn't and actually
those two moves are the top choices of
the computer right now
um all right well it is intense it is
wesley so in the movie he's been
thinking for
uh almost two minutes in his last move
now we have been seeing some graphics on
air things now air things we partner up
with uh with everything for this
tournament
and for the champions chess tour um and
it's actually following the air quality
where the players are sitting and we're
not right now
in the bottom of the screen seeing the
air quality where a niche gear is
sitting
and i can see a red cloud there which is
not the red is not good you want all the
um you want all the the things to be
green
so it's not the best air quality for an
hquery right now we'll take a look at
wesley so as well but we do have some
moves
uh david that's right so just as
predicted we've seen a pair of pawns
leave the board and black's rook was
under attack from white's bishop so that
rook has jumped forward one square
wesley so
still in control meanwhile we also see
his
his air quality levels i was actually
very lucky i got to
got to talk to some people from air
things and i heard that the carbon
dioxide levels you definitely want them
under a thousand yeah i think
ideally closer to 500 if i remember
correctly
and so even wesley so it's not red there
the carbon dioxide levels
um on the left we see 875 but i think
it's
still not ideal um yeah but for a niche
gear
it was whereas it was over a thousand as
you said that was
that was red and i mean one of the most
important things for chess players when
they go into these online formats
playing from home
must be the air quality where they're
sitting it must have
a huge amount to say that's right you
want you want fresh air you want your
brain working properly you don't want to
kind of
get a foggy mind and um air quality
is definitely a big factor it'll be
interesting to see what the players kind
of think about this as well whether they
maybe thought that this affected their
thinking or whether the
kind of the air quality in the room just
matches up with the critical moments in
the game yeah definitely the stress and
everything
so we uh we do have a slight criticism
from wesley so's play from bob beaky who
says
wesley obviously has the skill and
vision but he just
lacks that extra gumption he needs to
get more ruthless and punish his
opponents
more hashtag chest champs but having
said that
what move did we see on the board you
know we asked from
wesley and he's now about to deliver
because he has pushed his pawn forward
and he wants to take a wrecking ball to
why it's king
i love that kind of chess exactly that
pawn will act as a battering ram it will
just
explode open the kind of safe structure
that white has built around his king
right now um that will be safe no longer
black's pawn it will open up some lines
um even if black has to sacrifice
something
sacrifice a pawn or two as long as he
can open up lines towards white king
white's king i think wesley will be
very happy this isn't maybe the
traditional wesley so style to
go directly for the attack but i think
he's very adaptable
if the opponent allows him to attack why
not exactly
meanwhile anishigiri is in big trouble
that white rook in the bottom left-hand
corner i've talked about it it's just
not
participating in the action all of
black's pieces are head like
i mean they're just perfectly placed
they're heading towards the center
yeah yeah the last 5-10 moves have
definitely gone in wesley so his
favorite yes
and one of the things that we see in
poker is that when you go wrong you
really go wrong and you kind of call
that tilting and this is something that
we see in online chess that when you
lose one game that perhaps you weren't
expecting to lose
the second game is also a disaster and
maybe even the third
game and then you steady the ship and
things have started to happen
but we did see that with anishikiri yeah
on the last day of the preliminaries in
the first tournament he started losing
and then everything almost fell
fell apart exactly and he barely
qualified to the knockout stages i mean
are we seeing something similar
yeah he's got to make sure it doesn't
spiral out of control um
i mean i liked his opening strategy
originally i just like the
kind of ambition behind the strategy but
the last few moves that maybe shows that
he didn't understand
the ideas as deeply um as wesley so and
i think he's just missed the moment for
white um yeah he just needs to find a
way to survive this game essentially he
needs to build up some defense around
his king
needs to wait needs to find a way to
stop wesley so from attacking him
i mean it's easy much easier to say than
actually do it
but um if he survives this game he'll be
on a high and maybe he'll be able to
carry that momentum through if he loses
again that's
and by surviving like how because
traditionally when you try to survive
you can have two approaches which is a
you
just mix up the position make it as mad
as possible
or another one is like i've learned i
learned some football terms recently
park the bus where you throw every
single piece you have towards the
direction
of the king you're like no you're not
going to get through
so what kind of strategy would you see
from a niche here yeah it's difficult i
would love to park the bus in front of
the goal right now and
if white's rooks if you imagine them on
the right side of the board the queen on
the right the knight on the right then
white's king would feel nice and safe
but
um that takes six seven moves to park
all the pieces on that side and
meanwhile wesley so he's immediately
threatening to open up some lines
immediately going from the back
for the white king so parking the bus uh
jose mourinho the football coach who is
most known for parking the bus now
what football approach or what football
coach manager do you think would be best
at chess david
that's hard i did see this documentary
this amazon documentary with jose
mourinho and just
his motivational style was very
interesting i think he'd be great
as a chess coach um maybe not as a
player
oh that's difficult yeah alex ferguson
was always my idol yeah
he was quite mean you know i i mean i
yeah he used to do the hair dryer
treatment where
jerry is that where he basically
scrolled to the players i'm just saying
you're not
pulling your weight and uh i mean i
really like this term actually for chess
you know giving
i think a niche should have a word with
his pieces on their left
side and go what are you guys doing have
a manager approach
and talk to the talk to his players yes
exactly and uh
yeah no i i also liked uh alex ferguson
i grew up with him but he's a bit mean
well you actually played a premier
league football player i did
uh just a few weeks ago i do tell us
about that
i was a lot of fun so crystal palace
approached me and they said hey
you know you're local to the area you're
born in south london
one of our players would like to play a
game of chess against you and i was like
okay cool
and you know i gave them time odds and
then i felt bit guilty because he was
like
it was martin i played martin kelly he
was a great defender
and uh yeah then i had to hustle him a
little bit
[Laughter]
but it was a lot of fun and uh yeah he
kind of we discussed a little bit about
like these football expressions and
footballing
uh strategy or how it can be applicable
to chess
and uh yeah i think the video is on in
chess 24 actually yes we're going to try
to show it uh here in the broadcast as
well obviously but
okay i just took a glance at the bar and
it just shifted completely
way over to uh wesley's soul side what's
happening david
yeah it's not looking good for niche
gear right now and
we see the stockfish evaluations um or
the suggestions
below the board and the bad news for
anishkiri as white is that
black has at least three moves i think
plenty more which give a huge advantage
that means that wesley so will not make
a mistake he will not let this advantage
slip
and if we bring up the board we can see
why black is doing so well
this last move by white just shuffling
the rook across i was
i kept talking about how bad this piece
was in the corner he's tried to improve
it slightly
he looked like he's attacking a pawn but
actually that's not threatening a pawn
at all
white is attacking his pawn with two
pieces the queen and the rook but black
is also defending it with two pieces
and that means that white would lose
material if he captures that first
black is defending that pawn enough
times so actually wesley um
actually anishigiri's last move
improving that rook doesn't actually do
anything so he's given wesley so a free
move to attack
what i would do and what the computer
suggests suggests now is to just open up
a line
um for the black rook maybe by trading a
couple of pawns
and now this rook is extremely strong i
would love to maybe bring the other rook
a bit of teamwork
pair them up together um line them up
against this white pawn
very close to the uh what very close to
the king another thing you could do is
just bring your queen across one square
and maybe use this queen as well to
attack the white king all of black's
pieces will slowly start moving towards
that white king
meanwhile this piece is so bad at the
bottom of the board is doing nothing
it's just doing a defensive job it can't
really jump forward again
otherwise it will just be targeted one
bad piece makes the position bad
sometimes and white's night
is the problem absolutely and uh
one thing that's super important that
wesley has to do
is uh we came up a nice little rhyme for
this it's like
teamwork makes the dream work and uh
yeah this is absolutely
in wesley's interest he needs to be
using all of his pieces to start
attacking the king because he cannot let
his
advantage dissipate that's right i don't
think his advantage will dissipate
knowing him
he loves improving those pieces slowly
and the good thing for black is
there's no rush white's knight is going
to be stuck there for a long time
um so he will as black have four or five
moves to get ready for an attack
um it's just about as ivanka mentions
that teamwork using the rooks together
using the queen using the knight
and actually queen and knight are the
dream attacking combo
and knight is the only piece that does
something that the queen can't
um so black still has that queen and
knight on the board if black's queen and
knight can jump towards white's king
somehow
that will spend that will spell the end
so
um yeah very very tricky i expect to see
wesley so
i was going to say i expect him to make
a move soon he spent three minutes on
that he's just trying to figure out how
to improve his pieces
uh now it's time for black to bring his
queen into the game and therefore he
shuffles his queen across one square it
wants to
leap forward and attack that white king
it's looking desperate for any girly the
problem is his rooks have no targets
he brings his queen forward he's trying
to stop black from advancing his own
queen
queens are great in the center of the
board as well um as long as they won't
get attacked too much
but um that white queen is very much
doing a defensive job it's got no
targets
everything it tries to attack is
defended blacks i mean actually every
single piece of
blacks now is defended the coordination
there wesley so he just does this so
smoothly
you never see any piece out of place any
piece kind of
not coordinated with the rest of his
army meanwhile
white's queen is now in the black half
but the rooks are on the left the king
is on the right
um i mean there's so much danger
in the white position that's just
unbelievable you know and the funny
thing is that
if you look at white's king you can see
that super weak
on the light squares and look where
wesley has placed his queen
it's it's looking in the center it's
also looking
all the way towards the white king so i
am just really loving where this is
going you know so many
attacking possibilities yeah and you
know what i would
create now ivanka i would create one of
your favorite pieces
the octo knight
if we bring up the analysis board we can
see one of wesley's main options here
maybe he can exchange a pair of pawns i
would do this sooner or later probably
just to open up this line for the rook
and once he's done this it's time for
black to improve another piece this
knight
it's doing a good job it's nicely
protected by a pawn but it does an even
better job in the center of the board
this knight could jump in blocking
white's pawn but this knight is now
dominant look at how many squares it
creates we call it an octa knight
because it controls eight squares
it controls everything it's nicely
defended by the rook and then
and the queen next black will start
bringing his rook over his queen over
okay he's done it he's moved that night
immediately he hasn't traded pawns yet
that knight jumps forward and i think
this night is just so dominant that it
will spell the end
yeah and uh wesley has a lot of support
on twitter we have a tweet from
nebby he says go wesley
watching chess instead of writing my
paper
[Laughter]
yes cheering from the philippines yes
hello to you too
fantastic philippines all right yeah
that's right wesley so i mean he plays
for america now he lives in uh
america but yeah he used to play for the
philippines he grew up in the
philippines and he's got a huge fan base
there every time i log on to a chess
website there's hundreds of comments
from filipino
chess fans and um fantastic yeah maybe
that just gives him that extra energy
well he needs it because it's early in
the morning for wesley so well
not that early anymore it's uh around 10
o'clock or something like that
in in am for wesley so and each giveaway
playing from the netherlands
um so it's around five um half past five
for a niche geary
as wesley so made his move that's right
and actually
oh my wow he's just resigned oh
that's a very early resignation he's
given up much earlier than most of us
would
um but the position is so hopeless
white's king is actually in check
he would have to i think give up some
pieces just to survive
um i mean maybe we'll show that a bit
later why he resigned but that is
shocking i've never seen any girly lose
so badly with white before
wow he seems extremely low on confidence
yeah into losing 25 moves with the white
pieces it's
at this level it's unheard of so
yeah he's definitely looking at where he
went wrong to be honest i
agree with david david touched on the
thing that you know
anish chose an opening that perhaps he
didn't quite understand
all the subtleties and he just went too
passive
all right um a lot of games going on we
will go over
uh this very quick resignation from
manish giri later on but we have to keep
following round three in
their things masters and we will now go
to the game between magnus carlsen and
timor rojabov
and well not much to say about the bar
here what is it looking like david
yeah we do see that the bar gives a tiny
tiny advantage for white
um a quick material count though that's
the first thing i do in every position i
always make sure i know
um who's up on material who's up on
pawns and everything black is currently
a pawn ahead
but those pawns are weak and we've
talked about it before
knights on the rim are dim black's
knight they're on the right side
it's just not coordinated with the black
army at all so
white has full compensation for the pawn
that he has sacrificed
but he might be able to win it back that
pawn but will that be enough to win the
game
it's not clear meanwhile black's bishop
is very very ugly black's bishop blocked
in by all of its pawns but it's doing a
good defensive job
it's keeping everything together for now
i prefer white
but probably it might fizzle out to a
draw
yeah no i agree with you i prefer white
just
look at that night in the middle of the
board my octo nights this is so
beautiful
and yeah i agree with you that that
extra pawn doesn't really count for too
much because
white can simply win it and there's just
so much pressure in the position
so often sometimes the bar will just go
it's completely level yes it's fine but
it doesn't really anticipate like the
psychological pressure
that uh well black will be facing that
will be thinking
oh my position is so unpleasant and you
can see that things actually can spiral
that's right i mean it it might say that
the position is equal but as
uh in practical terms it's easier to
play white and it's all because this
black knight is so bad
and you compare it to this beautiful
knight in the center of the board
controlling so many squares
that being said roger oh look the bar
there i was going to say he's a very
calm defender
that last move i mean i think it's okay
to be honest um he's just brought his
king
towards the center maybe it was just
better to um
improve his night somehow maybe bring
the knight back before the king maybe
that was a
more of a priority um yeah i think still
decent drawing chances for rajabov but
much easier to play for magnus carson
and magnus
we saw it in the skilling open in the
first leg of the championship he's so
good at
finding these small end game advantages
once the queens have gone off grinding
out these
um these kind of small chances setting
traps for his opponent as well
um yeah i think once both sides tick
under three four minutes
then we'll see magnus make his move and
try to trick
raj above a bit later on it's a good
strategy i also have to remember that
the players
themselves cannot see the bar they are
only seeing the chess
position they don't know anything about
the computer evaluation because if they
did then
you know it would be like a form of
cheating to be honest yeah
and uh yeah so there he's unaware
rajakov doesn't
is completely unaware that whether his
position is totally
solid he will just have to sense it or
basically calculate it out
and uh yeah yeah my favorite scenario is
when both players think they're winning
because they can't see the bar they both
think they're winning
you've seen them both smiling and then
suddenly one of them the face drops
i'd love to see something like that
today i was actually
part of i was watching this analysis
where okay both players had never
competed
consulted with the computer and there
was exactly that scenario one was what
no i'm winning the other was like no
i'm winning how could you say i got an
amazing position
i think it was like two ships that we're
never ever gonna cross
well actually on these two players it
looks like they're both
losing but i guess they're only really
focusing on the board here right now
because it looks very tense and
interesting with the queens off the
board
still a lot of pieces in play here
that's right there's still a lot of life
so even if the computer were to say 0.0
there's still enough pieces to create
uh create chances for both sides
yeah i definitely think rajabov he knows
he's the one defending
magnus he'll know he's in charge but
it's just about um
kind of finding those practical attempts
giving rajabov the most opportunity to
go wrong so maybe he'll find a move that
gives uh black four or five different
options but it's just harder to choose
for black
with white i think anything um is
roughly level and
therefore okay magnus casting he just
improves his king slightly
that's another good tip you know when in
doubt in an end game once the queens are
off just improve your king bring it
closer towards the center we've seen
both players do that now
yeah you have this kind of uh like motto
in the end game like my one of my old
coaches told me he said to me
hurry but don't rush
the perfect balance yes and okay well
now we
have some decisions going to be made
because rajapov has attacked the bishop
and now magnus has captured that extra
pawn
so are we going to see a whole series of
trades and then
yeah i think actually rajabov he has a
bit of a key move right now
and he does find it he moves his rook
across one square he's lined up his rook
with the opponent's rook
so white's bishop there was stuck if
white's bishop had moved
white would lose that rook on the bottom
of the board therefore we will soon see
some train
some trades on that line uh black will
soon trade the bishops off
maybe the rooks will leave the board as
well um magnus carson though he still
does have a superior night so that's
what gives him the small chances
in this game and maybe even a superior
king
the king will come out into the action
oh that's what i love about end games
how the king
you know he was hiding before it was
just a feeble old man
it suddenly comes out with golden hair i
always think
that's the most tense part when you see
i would
just hate being in that part of the game
actually taking the decision to move my
king into the action
oh yeah well we're going to see it now
because there's been a whole series of
trades
and now the king definitely has to get
active
that's right so black's king at the
moment it looks nice and safely tucked
away but
it is just doing a very passive job
white his only plan magnus carson to try
and win this game i think is to use his
own king
to enter the black position it's very
tense
knight end games we say that they're
very similar to pawn end games if you
remove the knights in the book from the
board
if the pawn end game should be a draw
then normally it's still a draw with the
knight still on the board
and neither side has too many weaknesses
here neither side has a pawn that can be
easily targeted
so it's going to be extra hard for those
knights to jump around black is the one
though with the worst night so i would
try to improve that sooner or later yeah
all right well we do see
a lot of the games in this round as well
ending in draws david
and pantalari krishna has played draw so
has um
grishok and aronian and nakamura and
ponyachi
so wesley so the only one with a victory
so far
in this round anishkiri the only one
with the loss so far
and we know magnus he's played two draws
uh timor ajabo did get a win in the last
round so
minus carlsen he wants to win now he
wants to get started he said that
before the show started he said ah i
want to get
i want to be in killer mode yeah he
wants to but
i think rajabov he's going to try and
shut down killer mode and actually he
did find by far the best mover
actually as black black pushed the pawn
forward he's just trying to trade off as
much
as he can he's trying to get his knight
that black knight into the game
if white had captured that black pawn
last move with his own pawn in the
center there
then the black knight would have jumped
back out of the edge of the board
finally um i think that was a key move
from raj above
maybe magnus carson should have tried to
stop that move a bit earlier on
um and now we see rajabov just pushing a
pawn forward in the corner
he's going to try and push all of his
pawns on the right side there
the more pawns that leave the board the
closer he gets to a draw
we should also mention that if all the
pawns disappear
and if one side loses the knight if one
side has a king and a knight versus a
king that is a draw there's not enough
material left to checkmate
um so there's some room for room for um
yeah maneuver here for example rajabov
could trade off some pawns and then
sacrifice his knight for the remaining
white pawns to make a draw
and there we see magnus carson pushing
his king forward
i think black will trade off a set of
pawns now
um and good thing for rajabov is that he
does have enough time here
it's not the type of position where you
need 10 minutes to work everything out
two to three minutes should be enough to
help him guide this game to safety
is there anything magnus can do in this
position to just
tell us i'm going for the win here i
think he's definitely still going for
the win
[Music]
the only thing he can really hope for is
that he can somehow
paralyze that black knight but once that
black knight gets into the game
um i think we will be calling it uh
calling it today and actually we see
magnus his facial expressions there just
looking away
yeah i think he's kind of um accepted
the fact that
we're edging towards the draw yeah i
just love rajapath's expressions you
know he really
looks like he's almost full of this yogi
like you know
wow you know oh it's just brilliant
and he's sitting i think maybe he's
sitting in moscow or if he's sitting
home in baku in azerbaijan
i mean it's not early morning for him
it's uh closing into the night for him
but he's just
you know okay just see him calmly i
think this is just a kind of thing don't
get
over excited it's not over until it's
over i remember
once when i was playing mr david howell
[Laughter]
he was he was trying to beat me in any
way possible but he just wasn't i was
like calm down
i was like calm down you know he's just
trying to bluff you
i think sometimes you know magnus magnus
we've kind of spoken about he has this
kind of magical effect you know
he's so good at the end games and we all
know he is the big boss he is fantastic
and we do also know that he loves to
carry on
playing and torturing the opponent you
just have to kind of
no i'm not going to fall for that no i'm
not going to just going to keep it calm
and not make any critical mistakes and i
think rajabov he's not the
kind of guy who will get flustered or
who will panic
for no reason and i mean he's kind of
dressed like a jedi knight or something
or someone out of the matrix but
um i think that meditation that he took
a moment ago that will just give him
i'll give him the peace of mind to well
to hold this draw and his last move
is a very nice one he just pushes his
pawn forward now white's king
cannot move towards the right side it
cannot enter the position
because black's knight and black's pawn
combine to kind of create a fortress
just
preventing any advance of the white king
i think sooner or later
it will be time for white to just
exchange off another set of pawns
but then again that will bring the game
closer to a draw hmm
both sides a bit stuck here there's just
no way to improve the position for
either side
so magnus carlsen is thinking we know
that magnus crossing loves to win
how about this move david yep um that
shows that he is still trying to win
ah he's trying to i mean it's a bit of a
long journey
but white will use his king to try and
always come around from the left side
is uh making its march um
perhaps it might be would it be risky
actually to
get your king so far away from the right
side of the board
yeah well i mean magnus he's a brave man
he's going to spend the next five moves
trying to improve his king trying to
enter the black half
um that being said that white king has
abandoned its pawns right now so
raj above he'll be looking for a way to
try and um
try and maybe improve his knight improve
his king to get at those white pawns on
the right side
there we see rajabov again kind of
meditating but we could see him actually
whispering to himself he was working out
i was going to say he was working out
the consequences of this night trade
that he's just offered so the knights
are looking at each other right now
white could trade them i think that
position would still be a draw
um but yeah raj above just working out
yeah okay and they have been trained
i think we're going to see a bit of a
standoff here where the kings will
just will circle around some very
important squares in the center
but i won't actually occupy them because
okay and there you can see it the kings
are just
repeating and we do have a draw
another draw for magnus crossing in game
three against timor
rajabov and they are sitting there they
are looking over this
was there anywhere in in the game where
magnus could have sort of
uh done something differently to to get
the win here david
yeah i think this one was difficult
right at the end um i think rajabov just
defended
perfectly it's sometimes hard to break
down if your opponent does have this
type of fortress where you can't break
through
maybe earlier on in the game there was a
lot of tension maybe he could have kept
that tension a bit better but
if your opponent defends perfectly
sometimes a draw is a natural result in
dress
sometimes the drawers are naturals we
have seen a lot of drawers so far
natural start to a tournament players
not taking too many risks it's it's
not too much fun to to be behind after
day one so we
have seen some draws we did see
um in the first game that we followed in
this round though
we did see a win we followed the game
between anishigiri and wesley so
uh devastating loss for anish giri in
that game david and maybe we could just
uh swiftly go back to to that position
to actually see where
you know where anushkiri played
inaccurately to get that loss
that's right so um a few moments i think
in this game a few critical moments the
first one came in this position
um white has just retreated his knight
back it looks like a decent choice maybe
that knight wants to spring forward
towards the center a bit later on
wesley so he cut that idea out this rook
is on a great open line right now
and this is where i think it started to
go wrong for anishigiri playing white
anish pushed his pawn forward one square
but this pawn actually becomes a
weakness later on white's knight is just
terrible now tied down to this pawn
and this was the start of where things
started to go wrong uh
began to go wrong for anish wesley he
traded off
the best defender of white's king and a
few moves later
after some trades we did see it was time
for wesley so to push forward
he pushed forward trying to open up the
white king and
um if we whiz ahead we can see actually
why
white resigned in the final position
this knight firstly is so dominant this
octo knight this
powerful piece in the center and after
black gave a check
attacking the white king um anish we
were all surprised that he resigned
immediately
but um he would have to give up some um
well he'd just have to give up a piece
here i think if the white knight
captures this pawn
it is defended twice so black would win
a piece
um the knight for pawn is a decisive
advantage to the knight worth 3 the pawn
worth one
instead if he retreats his king then
black has a few choices sooner or later
he will jump forward with his knight
attacking the whoops attacking the white
king and this king is now
in check the king would have to set
sidestep
to the corner potentially and now black
could just bring his
queen forward actually threatening
checkmate
there's just no way to prevent this
white has to give up a knight for this
pawn
you'll be down a piece hopeless and we
said we mentioned it earlier the queen
and knight
perfect attacking combo the black queen
the black knight um
white's king is doomed and a bit of a
disaster spanish unfortunately yeah yeah
big disaster actually and uh we have a
tweet from
sarah may pimentel who says and that's a
win
for wesley so looking for a back-to-back
championship of the skilling open and
he's
gotten after a great start here wesley
absolutely he's showing that he's man of
the moment so far yes
all right well we do have another man of
the moment right now we are joined right
now by
grand master simon williams ginger gm in
london merry christmas
simon merry christmas everyone great to
speak join you again
you're feeling good and fresh we are
feeling good and fresh after
after the holidays david spending his
holidays in norway he hasn't been able
to
to have all the christmas food that he's
used to no that's right but i did get
snow today so i thought
uh that was a nice christmas tree so
maybe you can tease him a little bit
david with
how the turkey tasted yesterday
i saw the pictures of the snow actually
it looked look beautiful over in norway
and uh it's quite funny to be back on
boxing day looking at the action and
it's been a
another great day at chess so far right
definitely and i know you've noticed
a few moves that you wanted to talk
about and magnus carlson he's
not gotten off to the best start that he
wanted to a lot of draws here for
for magnus what do you think of his
start of the tournament
i am i think it's quite hard to play
after christmas day and i think it's
probably affecting some people more than
others maybe some people had a bit more
turkey
maybe a couple of glasses of wine a bit
more than others but um
we could see this in the first round
where magnus was playing against
rhodium and i don't know if it's
possible to look at the position on
about move
43 here and um in this position you've
got here
aronian now moves his rook into the
middle of the board rook
e4 and this position here
well magnus has an immediate win this
last mover ruining erroneous play was
actually a blunder
and it's really a bit unforgivable for
magnus to miss
the move f4 in the game he took the rook
off
but he could just move this pawn
forwards give a check
you should always look out for checks
and whatever black plays next let's say
black
captures that pawn or the white rook can
now swing over
and go a rook up and this would just be
easily winning for magnus so
the first game of the day i think it's a
bit of turkey blues going on there
magnus sees a little bit of warming up
as it goes um
so that that was one very exciting
moment well actually simon what does it
tell us when the world champion
uh who never misses these opportunities
misses this opportunity is he
simply a little bit tired in the start
here
i think he might just be a little bit
rusty i mean it's quite hard to get into
the swing of things that
athletes talk about getting into the
zone and chess is a mental game after
all and you've got to get your mind
focused even if you're
two percent off your game there's it's
very unforgiving chess you you can't
make mistakes you've got to have the all
cni
and you've got to spot these
possibilities and i think magnus is just
warming up at the moment
he's often a bit of a slow starter but
you know he's got to prove something
soon
all right and and there was another move
by magnus wasn't it that you that you
noticed uh today
yes there was one more moment and um
well i really like this next move this
is magnus again
with the white pieces and a lot of
players here would
castle kingside because castle is
supposed to be a good move right you
control the center of the board at the
start of the game
you get your knights and bishops out and
you tuck your king away
where it's safe bodyguards in front of
it the three pawns but
magnus instead of playing this move
plays
one of my favorite moves and i love this
move so much
it's harry four now i love giving the
pawns names as you might know
and the h pawn is dirty harry the h pawn
and here magnus pushes harry all the way
to h4
and this is a really aggressive move
because he wants to push
the neighboring pawn the g pawn up the
board next move
and instead of defending instead of
going a little bit passive with castling
he's going for the attack so it's not
like he's playing passively he is
playing aggressively
but he's just missing a little bit of
his normal flare
at the moment i feel definitely and
simon we do love that you're giving name
to
to the pieces we're actually talking a
lot in the studio about
talking to the pieces being like a
football manager talking to your players
is it easier
when when you give your uh your pieces
names
what it is i think you should talk to
your pawns but make sure you don't do it
when you're actually playing someone
because i've seen that happen over the
board
you're supposed to say okay right knight
you should supposed to be thinking this
where should you move yourself to to get
an attack but you shouldn't actually do
that
okay night where should you actually go
because that's a little bit odd
so do talk to your pieces but maybe keep
it non-verbal
when you're doing it make sure they're
all working together and they're all
playing the field
in the battle at the same time now is
this simply a tip for beginners or are
all of you
grandmasters are all of you talking to
your pieces like that in your head
obviously
i i think so i think you you've got to
get i mean at the end of the day chess
is based on war
and they're all your troops you're the
commander and if your troops aren't
doing the right things you've got to
command them to go to the right squares
so
if one of them is sleeping in the bed
you've got to say get out of bed
get into the battle go to the right
place on the battlefield so you kind of
are talking to pieces they got to have
some harmony
with them like you're in charge like
some you know you're creating a bit of a
great piece of music
but with your army so yeah i think so i
think you do have to talk to them
you do that as well if i could talk to
your pieces and maybe
give them a hard time if you're not
happy with them do i in fact i i do this
especially on online chess because you
know
anything goes there so i talk to my
pieces and i'm like come on
get go get moving i never do this over
the board i have to say
it would look weird as simon mentioned
but online
yep definitely okay so this is one of
the new things that we're seeing with
the online chats
more talking with the pieces yeah more
talking to the pieces more kind of self
critique you need to motivate yourself
and if you feel a bit sluggish and
not fully focused maybe like magnus
feels right now sometimes you just need
that extra energy that you
you get from uh screaming a few things
yourself in the mirror
wow um so simon we are very excited for
the
last round of the game only 12 players
since this is a major so they're only
playing 11 rounds and that means that
already now it's it's quite important to
to get in there for a niche gary for
example who's
had a slow start to the tournament now
what's your expectations now for the
last round of today
um well i think we've got to expect
magnus first of all because he's had
three draws to really come out punching
in this next game i mean he he's so
dedicated and he's going to want to show
that he can win this one
after coming second before anisha's
having a terrible start this often
happens you've got to just try to
rebalance yourself
because it's very easy to get a little
bit depressed with the way things are
going but
you just got to pick yourself up and
you've got to be like right okay
i'm going to i'm going to try again i've
got to try something a little bit
different
i'm not out of the competition quite yet
and it's it's a tester character if
anything it will show
who who deserves to be in the next round
uh in this
final round of the day hmm all right
well
it is boxing day isn't it in in uh in
england what what will the rest of the
day look like for you simon
i'm well i i think you've got to they've
got to show some boxing skills on the
board here
they've really got to be a bit violent i
mean chess chess
is kind of a violent mental sport people
think that's quite a weird analogy but
at the end of the day you
you've got to win the game and you've
got to do that by defeating your
opponent so
it's it's a proper boxing day massacre
maybe
coming up in his lunch what what would
you usually be doing david if you were
home in britain
today on boxing day i'd be recovering
from christmas day
probably i'd be eating all the leftovers
and
trying to find more presents that i'd
done around the house
um yeah it's a big day actually in
england i think national holiday as well
and
it's just great that everyone's spending
it watching some chess with us exactly
it is the best day
the way to spend boxing day yeah
absolutely you know you get to enjoy all
these
great ferocious chess players take
themselves apart
all right simon well we wish you a great
boxing day and we're looking forward to
see you again tomorrow
definitely have a good boxing day as
well i'll see you tomorrow thank you
simon
all right grandmaster simon williams he
is doing the ginger gm stream on twitch
so follow that as well
um as uh we will be looking forward to
the last round of today round four
but before we do that let's uh talk to
the players a little bit more
we asked them what are they currently
working on in chess take a look at this
[Music]
i'm trying to to be well prepared in the
opening but also try to get in good
shape i'm working a bit on my online
playing skills as well because with this
mouse it's also different
uh also gaming uh gaming helps i also
have started to play this counter strike
right try to
do some practice on internet contact in
friendship i think
it seems it's important for this first
time controls
and also to get used to calculate on the
screen
i'm just playing mostly online chess
trying to get
better and faster i did lots of puzzles
i think it's very helpful
also for your confidence you know when
you solve like 100 puzzles you feel like
you know you're smart
i think to feel good it's just half the
job done already
all right so the players are actually
currently mostly working on
online skills that's fun to hear david
what what
are you currently working on in chester
is it like an opening or
oh good question i haven't done enough
work lately
actually i did spend christmas eve
studying ivanka's favorite opening the
kara khan defense
i've been trying to find a new idea a
few new ideas there i play it from both
the white side and the black side
um i did do a few puzzles as well on
chess24.com so
um yeah i think as anish mentioned some
puzzles it's good for the ego it also
keeps the mind fresh
yeah yeah it's always a good always good
plan i'm a big fan of puzzles
absolutely i love solving them and i
also go on to chess 24 and i try to race
against the clock and
just get as many points as possible um
the one thing that's very addictive is
though to play chess just to actually
get out there just go online and uh play
a chess and one of the
most addictive things you could possibly
do is to
crank up the time to one minute to kind
of increase the
pressure and you're just there trying to
make as many moves as possible and pre
moves
and uh yeah yeah if you like your
adrenaline this is very good
but it can be a bit hair-raising at
times so is that what you're doing
actually more and more
playing online and playing faster time
controls all the time
yes
[Laughter]
yes it's you know what i can what can i
say i'm an adrenaline junkie i just i
love playing it and you're just getting
the pre-move and the thing
is when you have seconds left on the
clock the chest becomes
very random and it's all about setting
trips that
tricks and traps and when your opponent
falls into them you kind of get this
pure sense of elation and yeah all right
well the players in their things
monsters need to get their adrenaline
pumping before the last round of day one
uh we have finished round three let's
take a look at the results it was very
interesting actually
um a lot of drawers also in this round
um daniel dubois maxim vashi lagrav that
was a draw
so was uh david anton versus uh panther
harry krishna
magnus carlson and timor jabo that was
also a draw
and um alexander grishard versus lavon
ironian adroll ikar nakamura versus
a draw the only game that ended with a
win was the game between
esiso and anish giri wesley so the
winner of the first tournament in the
champions chess store was able to win
that game against
very strong players so the standings
very interesting we have four players on
two points after those
three rounds that is hikaru nakamura
timora jabba lavon
aronian and wesley so so definitely four
of the
very strongest players four of the
favorites just getting after a great
start here
yeah that's right and they're quite
likely to be able to push on in the next
few rounds that means there won't be
that many qualifying spaces
left for the rest of the field i think
we're going to see as the rounds tick on
especially now that they're all a bit
tired
we're going to see a lot of players
start making their move
all right clock is ticking towards the
last round of day one in the air things
masters and we have been looking at the
clock for each player because we know
this
online format people players are sitting
in their homes playing
and well hikaru nakamura must be feeling
a little bit better now because sitting
in california
it's finally not early early morning for
him uh longer ivanka
yeah yeah it's still early morning for a
chess player yeah
you must forget that it's just uh
closing in tonight
yes yeah this is not good news for a
chesapeake no player no
no player likes to get up early in the
morning we're all night owls right
well not all of us but no one is uh no
one is
six a.m ready with a mouse
but but it is interesting so we know
hikaru nakamura in this last round
it is 9 a.m in the morning for him he's
going to play levon aronian
it's 9 00 p.m for for lavon oroni and 12
hours different there
do you do you think that is actually
something that we can see when they play
david
in any way yeah i mean definitely we'll
we'll see by the
kind of the level of moves the intensity
of the moves who's feeling more awake
maybe
it'll be fascinating to see the air
quality in their rooms as well
i mean will it be better in the morning
will it be better in the evening after a
long game of i mean after a long
four hours of playing chess so many
factors here will
kind of decide those small margins all
right
well um let's take a look at the the
games that we will have
in the very last round of the first day
of the air things masters
we do have some very interesting games
coming up the first one
is between maxim vajrayela grab and
napogniachi the french versus the
russian daniana pomniacci had a horrible
start
ivanka does he really need to fight back
now he does absolutely need to fight
back especially because this
is the last game of the day and
no one wants to end the day on a loss so
he absolutely
needs to do something do anything draw
win
that's fine just no losing and then we
have the american wesley so
oh sorry levon aronian first against an
american
hikaru nakamura both players got off to
a very good start who is the
favorite david is it always here kara
nakamura when we're talking online chess
usually but aronian he's been so
impressive today and he does have the
white pieces traditionally he's very
good with white
nakamura maybe a bit more passive as
black
um he's very ambitious when he has white
but um yeah this time
it's so hard to call i'd slightly favor
iranian maybe yeah he seems so confident
all right
let's take a look at the other games
it's going to be wesley so he's facing
alexander grishock and i just can't
believe how confident wesley
seems today yeah he's fantastic to see
you know he
really played a fantastic game against
aneesh giri made it look super easy
i think he has to be the slight favorite
because of that also he was so
impressive in this killing open but of
course
underestimate alexander grisham at your
peril you know a three-time
world blitz champion yeah a great player
there and then another player on top of
the table
is uh team rojabo and he is going to be
playing
the player in the bottom of the table in
each geary
what do you expect from manish in this
final game of today david i think
just anything but a loss i think he
would take a draw right now because
you don't want to end a day with three
losses in a row i mean you just never
won three losses in a row we sometimes
call that castling queen side
because when we write down the moves it
means three zeros in a row and
um i think that that's the thing to
avoid he just needs to be solid
um and not gamble too much and then we
have a world champion magnus carlsen
who's been playing three draws he wants
a win
against pantala hari krishna maybe one
of the players that he will be able
uh to get a win in this tournament we're
gonna follow that closely and then also
in the last game daniel dubo he's gonna
play david
anton the two very young guys gonna face
each other here but
the game that we will focus on is this
game
the one of ronian has had such a good
start to the tournament versus
icarua also a great start to the
tournament yes
and uh hikaru playing from different
locations you can see we've got a
screen there so uh we heard rumors
didn't we david
that's right i do have some insider info
from one of
hikaru nakamura's one of his kind of
management team
and they said that actually the facility
he normally plays from like his office
um it had to be evacuated and there was
a covered outbreak so he had to go home
he had to set up everything a bit last
minute just in the last day or two
um so new location for him will he be in
his comfort zone will that affect him
well we'll find out and the moves are
coming fast and furiously
that's right so white opened with the
pawn in front of his king levon aronian
he's he can kind of surf with both hands
as we say
um it's a bit like tennis sometimes you
serve towards the left the right he can
open the game in
any way and we do see that hikaru
nakamura replied also with his king's
pawn
and a few moves later we see an opening
that we call the spanish
um sometimes called the roy lopez
opening as well um both players
are going to be very solid and there we
see white takes some space in the center
white
tries to occupy that midfield the center
of the board with some pawns
um nakamura jumped forward with one of
his own pawns kicking the white bishop
back
and now we see a trade in the center
and nakamura does fight for that space
we mentioned it earlier you need to
control the center if you control the
center you can decide later on whether
to attack on the flanks
um through the middle it just gives you
much more flexibility
um with your plans so nakamura now
pushing a pawn in front of his queen
asking levon aronian the question do you
capture me do you push forward
do you castle your king aroni has so
many things to do but it does look like
maybe nakamura is the better prepared
player he's a minute up
on the clock already and in fact they
are actually repeating a game that
hikaru
has played before this time against
shirov in fact it was played
literally in december 15th so not that
long ago 10 days ago
okay this is ah this is something i
haven't seen nakamura do before actually
so it's just a recent idea it must have
been what he's been studying
over the christmas break yeah and just
look at him he looks
super confident he knows that he's
looked at this before he studied it
and lavone perhaps not looking as though
he has so pawn takes pawn
that's right so we see we see a trade uh
well
it will be a trade of pawns in the
center white did capture a pawn
and rather than recapture that pawn
immediately
nakamura dropped back with his knight
we will see a flurry of moves we'll
recap the position um
in a moment with the board the priority
i think for nakamura was to get his
knights out
he wants to bring his king to safety he
wants to castle that king
over to the right there um that being
said nakamura he's
looking up um normally yeah he looks a
bit confused
normally i've noticed with nakamura when
he looks towards the left when he looks
up in the sky
it means he's trying to remember
something if he looks towards the right
it means he's a bit surprised
he's just trying to work things out and
then we see when in doubt
if you're a surprise just get your king
to safety yes and nakamura gets his king
nicely behind a wall of horns and in
fact this whole setup is something that
hikaru has not seen before
so that would be why he's looking in
that direction
because yeah they've departed from that
game and now he's either on his own or
he's trying to record the analysis
that's right so um levon aronian he's
having a bit of a thing here i expect to
see him bring
his king to safety um as well so a bit
of a copycat
uh move here from levon but maybe if we
bring up the board while aronian thinks
we can see the last few moves have come
thick and fast
um white played this move which is maybe
a bit surprising to a
um to nakamura he brought his bishop out
eyeing up
this queen indirectly behind the uh
behind the black knights
so one of those knights might be able to
move but both of them
uh or at least one of them will be stuck
um temporarily um nakamura was surprised
and
therefore he decided okay it's time to
get the king to safety and it looks like
irony has copied that
um at the moment white is a pawn ahead
this pawn
is however very weak we call these
doubled pawns they're on the same line
um and they're both isolated they have
no other pawns to protect them
so the front pawn is very weak it will
drop off sooner or later it might become
a battle
okay actually nakamura captured it
sooner rather than later it will become
a battle over these central squares now
white has this pawn on its own um it
might be a strength it can throw some
nice squares but it might also become a
weakness
later in the game very tense battlehead
definitely tense
and well guys i have to say we have two
lovely lovely tweets we have a tweet
from sean hagan who says
hashtag chess champs teamwork is
dreamwork
indeed i really enjoy listening to you
guys you have great chemistry working
together
so thank you sean and we also have a
lovely tweet from juan trujillo
he says i started playing chess again
after many years
the queen's gambit effect and discovered
that great tournaments are now streamed
with
awesome commentators so yeah
thank you so much to juan as well and uh
brilliant stuff keep your tweets coming
we will
just we will feature them on the show
and you can do this by tweeting us
using the hashtag chess champs and we do
also have that quiz going on
we do also have a quiz who is the
current
fischer rap fisher world champion yes
special right
of random yes the winner will walk away
with a one year subscription for chess
24 premium so
just uh tweet your answer to a hashtag
chesschamps and
i mean this is the last round so we're
very soon gonna pick a winner
we are definitely definitely again it's
gonna be one
year's premium subscription to chess24
that's a great prize
that is a great price all right well it
is le von eronion thinking i i've been
noticing we've been following a few of
uh levon's game same it seems it's been
playing very fast most of the time
yeah that's right i think just the first
game against magnus occasionally he
spent a few minutes here in there but in
general it was much faster than we've
seen from him
um traditionally he is quite an
instinctive player he trusts
his attacking instincts um and he's very
very confident he
i've noticed from playing against him
from analyzing with him he always thinks
he's doing well which i think is a great
trait
to have and a strong player you always
have to believe in your position
you can't get too depressed if your
position has some weaknesses and
if you're on the defending side he's
always very confident um
yeah yeah so and that last move as well
i think he's been surprised but he's
still playing relatively quickly that
last move has surprised nakamura who's
now got his head in his hands
do you think this is the phd and drama
that one of the
participants said
you know i just love it so expressive
and uh brilliant stuff
just look at him he's like what is what
am i gonna do there
but uh yeah i have to say i'm learning
something new every day and and actually
someone
who tabitha has left us a very nice
tweet she said
she's also learning something new every
tourney
tournament and we have a hashtag
octonite
mean girls thanks to kaia hashtag is
your rook happy david
and hashtag chess champs that means
tabitha was watching the last uh
the last tournament as well it's getting
open we talked a lot about those mean
girls
and we also have a very intriguing tweet
from
davies new jogana he says i think magnus
is
off today because he is following
fantasy football
you can see him looking left
occasionally distrusting him
that's what he's looking at yes because
we've been seeing that
all day he's looking all the time i
thought maybe he was looking at the sun
or the
the great view from wherever in the
world he is
ah but maybe yes perhaps maybe it's
football
he does love his football i was once at
a tournament with him it was the closing
ceremony and
all the prizes were being given out and
i think he'd won the tournament
but he was a bit late to collect his
prize because he was busy watching
football in the corner
exactly so the last couple of moves
we see nakamura still making a few faces
here and there
if we bring up the board we can see that
his last move very natural developing
move he's just
improved this bishop we talked about
bishops being on these very nice long
diagonals this bishop
will long term control some very uh
important squares
ironian he decided to snap off a pawn
here and this looks like it might
uh win a pawn for white this pawn is
protected by the knight so if we see a
trade then white has actually won upon
white has a two for one advantage on
this left side now but
i think more likely than not we'll see a
trade of knights first
so black will remove the defender of
this pawn and
after this knight is recaptured black
will just capture this bomb back
we're seeing a very level position both
sides equal pawns equal pieces
um everything very balanced i think both
sides have reason to be happy though
all right well interesting game can we
say
at this point that the players look like
they're fighting for a win here or
if they're playing safe it's tricky to
say i think
both players they wouldn't be
disappointed too much with the draw but
i think
they will be waiting for their chances
they'll be trying to set some small
traps here and there
slowly outmaneuver each other but a lot
of life left in this position for sure
yeah
i agree i mean if you look at the
dynamic potential and all the pieces you
can see that
both sides have got really good pieces
the position there's like hardly any
pawns on the board so therefore it's
open
and when it's open basically anything
anything can happen it's all about
playing your pieces to the best
moves and having the best plan and uh
yep there is the always danger that the
vacuum cleaner can come on and you know
all the pieces get vacuumed up but
you know there's still a long way from
that stage yeah yeah as long as there's
a few pieces on the board there's always
life
exactly these two players they do like
to
try and fight they both want to win
every single game they're not really
inclined towards those
um duller drawers positions that we've
seen a bit
a bit today so we did see that trade
that um i predicted and now levon
aronian he just shuffles his rook across
one square
he's attacking an undefended black pawn
with that white rook now
um nakamura he's got many options maybe
he'll just
try and defend that pawn um he could
defend that pawn with his queen instead
he decides to counter-attack black's
using his own rook
to eye up one of white's pawns um a lot
of white spawns there so
um very interesting move that decision
was made super quickly by nakamura
i think i would have spent a much longer
um a much longer amount of time
deciding whether to defend the black
pawn whether to counter attack but
nakamura as well it shows
he's confident um he's been very
impressive
um also in the last tournament of the
champions chess tour but also so far
today
and that shows in the speed of his moves
i quite like that decision by black
attacking that undefended white pawn now
with his black rook
yes definitely bold you know it's all
about the momentum in these types of
positions with aren't too many pawns
and uh hikari is kind of saying i'm not
letting go
and this is like such a talent actually
because you do have to adjust in chess
like when the position is a little bit
close there's lots of pawns on the board
you have to get used to kind of maybe
the idea of repositioning your pieces
and here it's all about putting your
pieces in the most
active posts and yeah definitely i'm
liking it as well
and i do have to say we do have the most
cutest tweet
we have a tweet from craig mack and he
says
i'm nine and loving watching this
tournament with my
dad thank you craig
fantastic it is yes nine years old that
was about when
magnus carlsen for example started to
get quite good wasn't it
yes yeah that's right and maybe craig in
a few years he'll be
uh competing in these online tournaments
if he if he sticks with the chess
uh maybe he'll be the next world
champion yeah let's definitely remember
the
name
actually one of our players didn't
actually get really good at chess until
they reached about 13 or 14.
that's david anton is that so yes
because you kind of assume that okay
they're all progenies by the time they
were five or something no no
they definitely have uh have a chance to
improve
hard work pays off in your teenage years
as well that's good
all right what's happening here
definitely intel is moving
that's right black's queen um well it's
normally not recommended to put the
queen in the corner the queen loves to
be
controlling lots of squares from the
centre of the board but here if we bring
up the analysis board we can see
that the black queen actually has a lot
of potential um so we left the position
here
white had a choice white decided to try
and trade these rooks
there was actually a small trap um that
aronian avoided if he'd got greedy if
he'd capture this pawn it's not defended
right now and white's attacking this
bishop
but this would have been a big big
blunder it would have been a
big mistake suddenly white's rooks are
lined up on the same diagonal and
black's bishop
would attack the first rook if that rook
moves it'll capture the other one we
call this a skewer
the bishop's kind of x-ray vision
attacking those two rooks instead
white offered a trade of rooks and black
played this very nice move
this queen lined up with its bishop
along this diagonal
but also protecting its rook
down this line very very nice kind of
multi-purpose move there
by nakamura but aronian again playing so
quickly i'm slightly surprised by the
speed of his moves he just ignored that
he just said okay i'm bringing my rook
to the center of the board
rooks love these open lines we've seen
it many times before
very sensible play by both sides
yeah definitely i mean i'm just really
liking what hikaru is doing
he's put his queen on the edge of the
board it looks like a strange square but
when you look deeper
it's supporting the bishop and then look
on that lined up on that beautiful
diagonal
and it's just like trying to play with
his pieces on
all sides of the board it's not just the
right side the left side you know
everything i love it yeah queens they're
so
agile they can i mean they can cover the
whole board in one move pretty much
so um having that queen in the corner
right now it might look
counter-intuitive
it's something that we might not be
looking for immediately
but yeah very nice move by
nakamura there and i think he'll be
deciding between
trading those rooks off now maybe black
wants to get the other rook
his other rook into the game sooner or
later um
yeah i think personally i slightly
prefer nakamura's position as black just
because that queen in the corner and
that bishop
it's just like the dream team isn't it
and they're just like
bearing down it's like lasers bearing
down on the white king
it's very very unpleasant i agree with
you i prefer picaro's position
it's like been an opening success but
having said that
lavon has been playing very fast and
very confidently so you do
do have to wonder a little bit yeah and
actually um okay nakamura has just
jumped forward as bishop attacking the
white rook
white can trade rooks now um or he can
jump up with the white rook and capture
an undefended pawn there but that will
just be a porn trade
um actually meanwhile though my eyes
have been drawn to the bottom of the
screen now we have seen a result already
between harry krishna and carlson so
harry krishna one of the lowest seeds
um one of the underdogs newcomer to the
event could draw against the world
champion
yes four draws for magnus carlsen in the
first
day of the everything's monsters after
saying i want to get off to your killers
start in the person
you'll have to do that tomorrow then you
certainly will have to do that tomorrow
right
yeah sometimes your your words can come
back to haunt you a little bit but uh i
don't think magnus carlsen will be
two-faced no
and i mean so he is on um two out of
four points right now four draws
decent start just not the start he wants
because he wants to win games
as everyone does yeah and that just
shows how strong everyone is in this
tournament how good they are
um even one of the lower seeds can
easily hold magnus carson to a draw
yeah meanwhile though in the current
game between iranian and nakamura we
have seen a trade of rooks
so black's queen we loved it in the
corner there but it's now in the enemy
half of the board it's in white's half
um it was eyeing up an undefended white
pawn so white just
moves this queen forward just one square
defending
all of its pawns um yeah i think it's
time for nakamura to try and get that
rook
that black rook into the game what about
because we saw it a lot in the queen's
gambit the the netflix series that
best did beth harmon really didn't like
double pawns
and now there is the opportunity for
black to trade the bishop for the night
and uh do what beth really disliked you
know
gave have abba double pawns that's right
actually
um what about that that's a very i mean
it's a crucial moment actually now
um and that's a very kind of poignant
point ivanka um
if we bring up the board we can see that
there's a crucial
moment about to arise potentially black
does have the option to capture this
knight with his bishop this bishop looks
really good in the center
but you do give your opponent these
doubled pawns these pawns are actually
very weak now this pawn is now isolated
white's king is very open and nakamura
he has gone for this
yes because he's done it so okay and
he's created an octo night ivanka he's
put a night in the middle of the board
beautiful stuff yes but the bar isn't
loving it
okay well i did go back yeah
yes that's the thing sometimes it's like
the bar doesn't approve of our choices
but it's just
it's irresistible because look at hikaru
here now
but both players i know one is leaning
forward the other one is leaning back
and they're both kind of
shrugging their shoulders and yeah doing
some sort of stretches
oh what was that it looked like uh
hikaru was just swatting away a fly
maybe
um actually maybe if we can see the
humidity levels or the heat the
temperature
maybe it's just very warm um i think
he's in
is he in california yeah he's in
california in california right now so
probably very warm
where he is meanwhile another thing that
surprises me
actually shocked me even is the speed
with which levon is taking these huge
decisions
he accepted these double pawns so
white's king is never going to be safe
now
um oh actually levon shaking his head um
i was going to say
yes white king very weak potentially
white pawns also very weak
but he's still playing almost instantly
he's still um
still got nine minutes after 22 moves
usually we'd see those big decisions
players taking four
five six minutes on each one right um
he's taking only six minutes in total
for so many key decisions already
exactly and now there is the big
decision like can hikaru just get
greedy and grab a pawn because i would
be certainly
out there and he's done it he has
grabbed the pawn
and now it's up to levon to actually
prove what he has in
mind because i don't see it to be honest
yeah that's right
it's not obvious at all why white
sacrificed that pawn
um okay nakamura leaned back i think he
might have missed that move
um white bishop jumps forward to attack
that black knight in the middle of the
board that black knight was so dominant
so strong white's trying to get rid of
it
um so white temporarily is down upon
he's sacrificed to pawn
but if the queens come off if white can
get rid of that knight in the middle of
the board
white will likely win his pawn back
we also note that the queens they're
staring at each other white uh right now
but
white queen is actually protected by
that dark squared bishop
um so that dark square bishop would just
jump back and
capture if the queen's dis uh if black
decides to trade the queens off
i think this is a critical moment if
nakamura can find a way to keep the game
going
um then he'll i mean of course he'll try
but
it does look like we might see a few
trades well
more than a few i think after that last
move just protecting that night we will
see
yeah we're going to see it here you know
there's going to be quite a few trades
and uh all day the vacuum cleaners out
and
uh we're going we're heading into the
realms of a draw
but uh we do have a tweet from leandro
campello who says
it's very interesting watching the best
of the world
in chat playing in different places of
the earth
you know that's one of the fantastic
things about online chess okay you can
see the players all bashing out their
moves
and here they feel their masters are
finding the repetition
they found it in the most unusual way
and there we are yeah
it is a draw for these two players
who've been playing very good all day
lavon aronian's been looking like he's
so confident
and and hikaru nakamura as we know he's
always one
to count in when we do the online chess
yeah that's right and
i mean just ironian's kind of calmness
there was very impressive he just traded
everything
off um he knew he was fully in control
those double pawns at the
at the end don't make a difference
because neither side has enough material
left to checkmate the other
um the rooks balance each other out the
pawns balances each other out and
um i was very worried for white i would
have panicked myself but i run in so
quick so calm
just completely neutralized nakamura
right um i'm
i'm absolutely surprised by that
actually how quickly
he played and you know took all those
decisions
almost instantly because that's one of
the things we're taught as a child you
know
do not take just quick decisions like
that you're bound to miss something it's
going to be superficial
take your time sit on your hands sit on
your hands yes um
but okay it worked for him it just it
just shows his own form
that's right it shows he's on form and
it also shows that both players i think
they're pretty happy with how the first
day's gone
they've both managed to get a win under
their belts they know they only need to
get in the top eight
out of 12 players to make it through to
the quarter-finals and to make it
through to the knockout stages and
i think maybe both players are a bit a
bit tired they just wanted to
rush through this one and uh move on to
tomorrow
and two and a half points for for both
players that is a good start to the
tournament and we know with only 12
players
they only have 11 games now to to
qualify for the quarterfinals ivanka
right they only have eight games left
and uh yeah absolutely
they just have to be calm not do
anything drastic because it's
only the bottom four that get knocked
out
top eight go through to the
quarter-finals and that's
where it matters all right well they
they should be feeling confidence
after after this um this first day and
for
um we did see the clocks actually uh for
hikaru nakamura it's still
quite early in the morning actually and
he finished day one so
so what will the next uh the rest of the
day look like for him will he simply
start preparing for tomorrow
um yeah i think nakamura he just loves
chess that much he will be studying for
sure but
i think he's earned himself a nap as
well if it were me
waking up at six o'clock in the morning
to play against some of the best players
in the world i just want to
make sure that i recovered afterwards um
so yeah
maybe enough maybe some chess prep who
knows with nakamura who's
he exactly who knows with nakamura we're
looking forward to see both of these
players again tomorrow we are trying to
get a hold of lavon ronia would be so
nice to hear from him i'm just curious
about how he's feeling today because he
seems
uh well actually i think we we are
joined by levon aronian hi levon
hi guys hi merry christmas merry
christmas guys
we've been so entertained with your play
today lavon you seem
so calm and confident can you tell us
how you've been feeling today
i think the first game didn't go
so well so
i i was in a bit of a trouble against
magnus
but after i survived that then i got
enough confidence
so i managed to recuperate
and what have you been most happy about
today is that when obviously against uh
anish geary that
seemed very uh dominant to play your
play there
yeah i've uh i played to the niche many
times it's a great theoretician
and when you play against a great
territician you need to surprise them
early on
and i think i managed to surprise him
with this rare uh
line and
later on of course both of us could
improve on our play but generally
i had much more time so i had enough
time to think
and to come up with the right moves and
uh so yeah i'm very happy with that game
so lavon you mentioned this first round
game with magnus being quite difficult
there was a key moment
um that we noticed uh we saw you i saw
it
you saw it immediately yeah well what
did you think then when magnus
didn't he missed it i thought that
uh i was lucky in this game and i will
probably survive
do you think that that luck is a sign
that this tournament is an auspicious
one for you
um well you know it's christmas
i have to have the christmas cheer and
love for each other
and this is is this the first time that
you've been playing chess over christmas
no we usually play the world
blitz on the same dates
so how are you spending christmas uh
lavon obviously playing chess now but
have you had
a few days to to relax
yeah well i've i'm doing my favorite
things playing chess i've played say
yesterday the day before
so it's a wonderful christmas
fantastic and what will tomorrow be like
you know after
first day you are currently in top of
the table with uh
with uh hikaru well it was a
tough pairing today and i think i uh
i managed to stay solid so i'll
try to play better tomorrow and
try to be more solid more solid than
ever
and and how do you prepare in the
mornings before the
games begin well i went for a
run today so it's about
minus five so a refreshing activity
but i do it in the mountains it's full
of snow it's
very romantic but i love it
and live on in the skilling open the
last uh champions festival tournament
we did see your biggest cheerleader your
biggest fan ponch
yeah do you have him here with you today
cheering you on course
here
our favorite dog it is oh
exciting
you're a star
is that comforting lemon to having with
you when you're playing
absolutely absolutely he loves watching
and he's always there
when i played badly to germany
so he would have been proud of you today
uh for
my game against any stefan it was a
punchy like attack
okay we're here just to get a treat you
know type of attack
of course we hope you have a great
evening with uh
ponchuk is that it
uh thank you for joining us and good
luck tomorrow thank you guys
thank you thank you
that really is a very cute dog he is
cute yes absolutely i'm impressed by his
fitness regime as well
running in the mountains i i do recall
actually when i was playing in a
tournament
that we actually saw him hiking up a
mountain and we kind of kept pace for
maybe
literally a minute and then he was up
there
that's it everyone's so good nowadays
that tiny margins it's this extra one
percent of energy that might
might give you victory so these top
players especially for lavon maybe
um he's one of the older players in the
group um yeah i mean the fitness regime
is incredible that's why they're at the
top of the world
very very professional yeah absolutely
well uh
the final round of day one of their
things master is still going on and we
are now
jumping into the game between downhill
dubo and david anton
and i'm just noticing the bar uh is
donald dubo winning this game
oh this one is very tense so the first
thing i notice is that daniel dubov is
actually down
a piece black has an extra night
that being said white's position looks
beautiful the queen is dominant
in the center of the board white's pawns
there um
white's very far advanced pawns you can
see the black queen it's very passive
just blocking one of white's pawns
black's king is also potentially weak um
this is
in my eyes classic dubov he loves to
sacrifice he loves to give up pieces
knights bishops queens he doesn't care
he just wants to give them all up
but somehow he always manages to create
this kind of initiative this momentum
all of his pieces are always perfectly
placed and the enemy king is
always weak um david anton shaking his
head there just pushing a pawn forward
maybe stopping the white queen uh queen
from swinging across and giving check to
the black king
it's very difficult for black it is
absolutely difficult
because also one of the things when you
are material down but you know you are
fighting hard for an attack
you do have to remember can the defender
bring in that extra piece to defend
and in this case no the attack is
happening on the right side of the board
that's where the king is
on the left side that is where the extra
pieces are they're doing
nothing so so i mean i
really love dubose position but of
course there
there is always the issue that's at the
back of your mind you are thinking
you're a piece down you have to do
something
and uh most most players actually can't
relax when they're a piece down
they can't get used to the fact that
they get they could potentially lose in
the long run
and uh dave duval is devolve is not one
of them because he just retreated his
queen
and is now attacking that pawn that is
all alone
on the right side of the board that's
coming in the queen is coming in
that's right and actually um you guys
were asking how i spent my christmas
just a few days ago um i mean it's such
an honor but i i was able to watch
dubov and uh daniel dubovov on chess 24
on the youtube the twitch channels he
was explaining this game i mentioned
earlier the game of the year
where he defeated sergey karjakin with a
series of sacrifices he sacrificed pawns
uh he sacrificed his queen sacrificed
everything in that game pretty much
and he was explaining his thought
process and he just mentioned he
loves being material behind because it
gives him nothing to lose
um if your piece is down already then uh
you can just
kind of with a clear conscience you can
just attack and go for the opponent's
king so
um yeah that's what he's going to do
here i think very very shortly black's
queen now
is forced to zoom across and protect its
king
protect that black pawn on the right
side um i think it's time for white to
just talk to his pieces
daniel yep daniel do bobby internally he
was talking to his pieces there he was
asking which piece needs to be improved
and he decided it was that rook
that rook wants to zoom up the board
yeah all the way up there to
the same line as the queen it would be
protected
by a pawn it would also attack the queen
and the bishop therefore david anton he
tries to prevent that he's offering a
trade of rooks
yes and uh but now the position is
starting to leak a little bit
for for david anton because you can see
pawns are going to perhaps start
dropping
and i'm slightly worried because white
has this amazing
pawn that is right in the heart of the
black position it's two squares away
from
being promoted into something like a
queen so i am
super super worried okay and now dubois
is
maintaining the tension you know this is
such a sign of class you know because
maybe i would have been thinking about
trading rocks and grabbing the material
dubois is like nope
i'm just gonna play with my extra
material just keep my
um keep my material on the board and
just
keep the pressure on the board that's
right when you're attacking especially
when your piece is down you need to keep
fuel uh you need to keep potential
attackers on the board
white's rook again dubois talking to his
pieces white's rooks weren't connected
that rook that was on the left side i
mean it's still on the left side it was
doing nothing up there so he's just
retreating it connecting his rooks
saying to black
you can trade but then i'll have another
rook to join the attack a bit later on
and
um just bring his queen forward one
square
but doesn't this allow the thing that's
doesn't under this allow me to
well white to push however i want to
play this move
push the pawn i love pushing pawns and
now it's going to get one step closer
away from being a queen
and uh that's right so white could that
i mean that pawn up there in the middle
of the board
it could push it one square further to
its goal of getting to the end
of making a new queen um it would attack
the two black rooks so black
looks like he would lose a rook but he
can use his uh one of his rooks to come
down
and trade um and that would give check
to white's king
so we'd see a trade of rooks and then
black would just keep his
other remaining rook safe i think that
is one potential option
dubov knowing him though he's not in a
rush to
to deliver the killing blow i think he
can even just slowly improve his pieces
here all right and
and as he is slowly improving we are
joined now by anish giri who finished
his last game of today hi anish hello
hello how are you
hi we're good how are you feeling good
good
um i just saw my my flower ways pop up
there is you see you see that as well
let's just
actually see it's easily beautiful no
it's some magic you're getting
you're getting a magic show here very
nice and a merry christmas
yes thank you likewise likewise
correlations or well happy holidays to
everybody
happy holidays um how have you been
feeling today on each
well i've been feeling okay but i'm not
i haven't had uh
yeah very good score so far so i have to
work on that that's for sure
we we followed closely the game with
with you and lavon ironian and we were
very shocked when we we came into the
position and especially with the clock
um he was still up on 15 minutes when
you were down to one minute
can you take us sort of through what
what happened with you
and with your energy level maybe in that
game
um yeah a few things didn't go as
planned in the opening
and uh yeah it just i don't know i was
just doubting too much it was too too
interesting the position so i was
thinking about all kinds of options
um and at the end of the day you
couldn't couldn't make choice
um yeah you know when you play rapid
chess you gotta be more practical you
gotta
make these calls you just gotta take the
decision one or the other but do it
faster
so yeah it was a little bit trusted
there at the start and then the rest of
your games
um they ended in um
[Music]
well you had not well not 12. oh yes i
lost one more and
yeah today is really not a good score
for me so far yeah so nothing to be
proud of but uh
there are quite a few rounds left so
there's always hope
definitely always hope and
so are you're saying uh you're feeling
hope but are you also feeling
distressed because when it is a major we
know that it only is 11 rounds
of the preliminaries are you feeling
some sort of stress or are you confident
that you can make a comeback here
stress because of chess really
oh no no why would i be stressed my air
quality is excellent
life's good i'm not stressed at all it's
not about no it's not about stress it's
more uh it's more that you play
so many good opponents or some
excitement there by the way happening
but you play so many good opponents
and uh yeah sometimes you're gonna win
sometimes you're gonna lose uh
the stuff that's life we actually you
didn't you didn't mention the air
quality
uh anish we have partnered up with air
things to follow the air quality did you
actually follow your own air quality
today
well the thing is i i cannot do that um
in between my games because you know i i
figured out this room it's pretty simple
if i don't open the window for a while
the air quality drops because there's
too much co2 so there are two solutions
one is i stop breathing which isn't very
good
the other uh is that i open the window
like again but if i do it again i'll
freeze so at some point
i just made a choice to to go on with
the
with the bad air but at least not freeze
and keep breathing but
it doesn't really work out well so maybe
i should change my strategy yeah because
you see actually your co2 level is is
very red it's not good at all
no no but that's i mean you know i i i
can't stop breathing but that's
all that then my other levels are gonna
go down so it's not so simple
well maybe you can blame your two losses
on the co2 level today then that was the
plan that was a plan hopefully
tomorrow i'll prove that it's not just
about the air quality but also about
quality of your moves
all right anish um thank you so much for
joining us and good luck tomorrow
looking forward to seeing your comeback
tomorrow
thank you thank you hopefully thank you
wow
all right um interesting to talk to you
and there is a lot happening here are we
simply seeing daniel dubo winning this
game now
um we are again but he did lose the
thread for one move david anton did have
one move to get back into the game a bit
earlier on
and actually at least equalize the
chances but
he did miss that opportunity and once
again we do see daniel dubois in control
the computer says
plus 10. that is a winning advantage
that's equivalent to having an extra
queen pretty much
and actually we do see daniel dubois he
did win a bishop he's won the night so
actually he's the one who's a piece
ahead um black's queen it looks like
it's very dangerous
in white's territory there but actually
there's no immediate threats
white's king is relatively safe
protected by its queen
i think this one won't last too much
longer david anton he tried to set some
tricks he tried to
muddy the waters and complicate things
but unfortunately it wasn't quite enough
yeah we do have a tweet from steven
vessio who says
duboff is always so creative really fun
to watch watch so yeah i could see that
there was so much excitement happening
in the board you know i just
love how he played with the piece down
and uh yeah
we can see now that uh dubois is
completely
winning now you just compare the kings
and compare material
why has how many pawns up i'm not very
good at math white has three extra pawns
right now white's king is very safe i
think um
black can give a check with his queen
but white's king has enough pawn shelter
around it therefore david anton is
trying his best
to keep the threats up he's brought his
rook across he's talking to his pieces
that rook was doing nothing
but i think it's too it's too little too
late right now um
and yeah finally that pawn starts
marched much towards the queening square
this is what i wanted to do about 20
moves again
[Laughter]
queens what do you want for christmas
many queens many queens yes many queens
many victories
yes all right well obviously he can't
move his queen
yet because that rook is there but uh is
is this a long-term plan or how long
term is it
yeah it's not very long term
unfortunately for david anton
um daniel duval of there as well just
defending that pawn with his rook
black's rook is trapped it's stuck there
stopping the white pawn from advancing
um meanwhile he's still three pawns
behind um okay he's using his king
to try and capture that white pawn but
even if he does that will not be enough
he will still be many pawns behind
black's king is also weaker than um it's
white counterpart potentially
um and we do see daniel dubois moving in
for the kill
that white queen is going to drop itself
up there on the
right side capture that black pawn and
offended it will be game over and i
think
i think you're going to see david anton
call it a day i think
just by his body language it just looks
like
just to give a few sprite checks and he
just cannot
the the thing is he's so many so much
material down that he can't just
hold the position tight he has to do
something yeah i mean black is
really struggling he can't trade the
queens he can't trade the rooks he can't
uh winners or white pawns all of those
would lead to
hopeless end games um and now we see
dubov
so classy just centralizing his queen
that queen the white queen controls so
many squares
black's queen meanwhile is very sad um
on the edge of the board
yeah indirectly as well the white queen
is attacking the black king
so black's king will probably have to
move yeah and if he does that then he
can
another pawn can drop off on the
left side so yeah just a little bit
hopeless i
really think that anton will call it a
day soon because four pawns
four points down right six versus two
it's like in sport if you have six
players the opponent only has two you
will overpower them every time so
um yeah david antoine i think he's just
going through the motions he doesn't
want to resign yet
maybe he just still feels he's getting
into his rhythm he wants to click the
mouse a few more times
but yeah this game is almost over
is it just sometimes you just you're
just not
ready to face the loss so sometimes
you're just
moving the pieces just a little bit
longer yeah i agree
sometimes it's just like mentally you
just have to play a few moves here and
there
and just kind of okay fine and then find
the resign button
and sometimes it's actually because it's
difficult to find the resign button
i know i haven't i haven't resigned
because i was like where is it where is
it
and i ended up playing and you're not
used to pushing in the resign button
that's why which is a good thing it is a
good thing yeah
and we see the advantage on the bar now
saying 15.
how much is 15 in advantage in chess um
normally that is i mean it's a winning
advantage for sure normally that's
equivalent to
being having for example extra queen and
an extra rook
um yeah that's a killer advantage in
here we see that white has started the
final chase
of that black king white has given a few
checks the rook now gives a check to the
black king
the king is going to sidestep but now
it's saying 100
i'm guessing that's uh winning yeah that
means yeah you can't even get 100
the pieces together don't add them up to
100 do they but that means there's a
forced checkmate on the board
um i think checkmate is inevitable and
we do see david anton has resigned
actually
david anton he did resign the player
that was voted back into the tournament
he he was knocked out in the
preliminaries in the first tournament
but uh many fans out there so he was
voted back in
daniel dubo getting a win here and that
means that donald dubo
is heading to the top of the table are
we a little bit surprised
by this or is donald dubo actually
someone we have to um
talk about as one of the favorites here
well go i'm not sure whether he's one of
the favorites but to be honest
all 12 of these players are just so
magnificent it doesn't surprise me if
they're leading the pack
on day one they're absolutely fantastic
players danny deborah has certainly been
a one to watch for many years now
he's incredibly strong he plays some
brilliant chess so
i'm not surprised that he is on a plus
score
also we should mention that he's one of
the few players in this past year who's
won a tournament in which magnus carlsen
and nakamura have played in
online so he does have form he does have
this track record he's extremely good at
rapid chess
former rapid world champion this is his
forte and he's looking so confident yeah
he is looking very confident
and uh um i mean being a russian
we have a lot of russians in this
tournament alexander grisha
um how how is daniel dubo
doing in this bunch of all the russians
yeah he's uh
definitely up there nepomniacci is the
strongest russian player
and grishak has been stronger one of the
strongest ones for many many years
and duboff is certainly an upcoming you
know he's definitely
fighting for top spot yeah he represents
this new generation
they've got completely different style
they've been kind of boosted by the
kind of rise of uh technology and
computers and
um he's definitely used those tools
those skills to create his own style as
ivanka mentioned earlier and
he can beat anyone on his day um the
others may be a bit more consistent a
bit more steady but he
when he's on top form it's like watching
a masterpiece
wow well talking about style so we know
that the russian style is
very much about studying uh spending a
lot of time
studying chess whereas magnus carlsen
maybe been more known for playing chess
a lot more
is donald duboil actually maybe doing
more of what magnus carlsen is doing i
think he's
kind of married those two styles he's
playing bit of both um he plays a lot
it's no coincidence he's part of magnus
carlsen's team he i think they've played
training matches against each
other but he also he loves these
sacrifices and he studies those
much uh much deeper than maybe anyone
before him
lots of players they'll study these long
slow strategic positions he studies
these beautiful attacking attacking
lines and
um i wouldn't be surprised to see him
one day challenge magnus carson for the
crown
ah really okay well isn't it a bad idea
for him to be
to be the second of magnuson just giving
him all his ideas
maybe he's also learning some of
magnus's secrets well
that's one of the great things about
duboff actually he's not afraid to play
his
novelties he says that's fine i'll
create new novelties
doesn't matter all right well the first
day of the everything's monster
is closing in on the end but there is
uh still one game going on my simbacci
legravagnanda pomnyacci
um is still playing we've seen a lot of
draws today
um are you surprised by that or is that
just typical first day
that's what it's like yeah i i'm not too
surprised i think first day
nobody really knows what kind of form
they're in they're all a bit rusty
they've been celebrating christmas
um i think a couple of the draws were
due to nerves a couple of the draws
they're just saying
okay i've won a game already i'm just
going to hold my position
i'll let the others kind of fight it out
for those qualification places so
i think the next day the next two days
we'll see a lot more blood on the board
wow and the final game uh going on we're
jumping into
the end game here maxim vagier legrav
and jana pomnyacci the bar is saying
completely draw
davey what are you saying um
the bar might say a draw and a draw is
definitely the most likely result
because we might see
a couple of pawns leave the board
neither side will have enough material
left to checkmate but there's still life
there's still life white has this very
kind of promising pawn on the left side
there which could just run home
um napoliti's last move with the rook we
see it on the board is highlighted with
those
yellow squares that was his last move
he's trying to get that pawn he's
trying to capture it um if black can
remove that pawn from the board
um the remaining white pawn then black
will be safe it should end in a draw
so it's all about whether maxine vasily
grav if he can keep that pawn
he might be able to keep some winning
chances white has two rooks
black has a rook and a bishop and
bishop's normally worse than the rook
but black does have this extra pawn as
well so
roughly balanced chances but still some
life left
yeah definitely there's while those uh
those
back queen that left pawn on the left
side still exists there's gonna be some
chances but i do worry about
black's very advanced horn it's one
square away from
queening it's there in the center and uh
there's a lot of risk involved in uh
yeah that last decision to kind of allow
black's pawn in the middle there to
allow that one to survive
that's very very risky from facility
graph it shows he's playing for the win
so white is playing for the win
but that could backfire and we saw that
on the pontiac's face he did frown and
now black's king is advancing
and no wonder maxim is feeling fresh
look at the air quality
that air things is providing us with
he's just he's got the perfect air
quality
right yeah wow yeah the air things guys
they said
around 500 to 600 is perfect um humidity
looks perfect too
22 degrees nice temperature i'm jealous
yes wow 34 humidity
beautiful so even if he's been sitting
in this room for
many many hours now he's been able to
keep the air quality great and
i mean even if this is looking like a
draw if there was to happen something
very dramatic here
at least his air quality would be
perfect to do something and we saw it
affected anishigiri potentially i mean
he had a bad day
maybe it was just coincidence that the
air quality wasn't great in his room but
maybe i'll be messaging him later i'll
say just put on loads of coats and open
that window
being cold is better than having bad air
quality yeah definitely you got to have
good air quality because
does maybe kind maybe it's something
like a hidden thing actually that
mistakes that we make we think it's heat
in the moment is actually due to bad co2
levels
for sure interesting okay so maxim is
one of the players that have been able
to put up
our air things piece to actually monitor
his air quality
unfortunately annapolis hasn't been able
to it's been hard to get the device to
him in
uh russia that's what it's like
sometimes with the covet
restrictions hard to to send stuff but
very interesting to follow mexicans air
quality
yes and uh meanwhile white is trying to
push his pawn closer to his end goal of
getting to the uh black starting rank
white needs to try and make a new queen
but black's last move with that bishop
it does control the key square um
it does control the promotion square of
that white pawn
uh black's rock as well doing a great
job keeping an eye on that pawn
from the back um from behind that pawn
it's
kind of launching a suicide mission it
wants to be taken
if black's rook now if it jumps up and
captures that pawn then black rook
the black rook loses defense of that
pawn in the middle but this time
this time it's the prominent who says no
i want to keep the game going because
look at that pawn that he has the thing
is that black has two pawns
and yes white has this beautiful pawn on
the left side
but you know here it comes pawns are
running
here comes the other one oh dear me this
is very tense yeah and the white rook
um normally we say rooks are better than
bishops rook's worth five points
bishop's worth three normally
um that white rook at the bottom of the
board there it's so bad
it's just keeping an eye on the black
pawn it can't do anything else
it's basically like playing down a piece
um that black pawn in the middle is so
strong that it's keeping a whole rook
busy
yeah this one i think black
i was about to say it's much easier to
play black although it should still be a
draw with best play
but now um it's time for black to bring
his king forward
he does it he's going to attack that
white rook at the bottom
white is going to have to lose that rook
for a pawn i think maxine vazquez he got
brave
three or four moves ago he tried to play
for a win but it's going to rebound
black's moves are so easy and so natural
he should just bring his king
yes to attack that white rook and he's
done it he's now okay now that rook
has to move and uh goodness me
yeah and the key factor is as ivanka
mentioned black has an extra pawn on the
board so
if the white rook loses itself right now
if it has to give itself up
for that black pawn um if if you imagine
all the pieces of the board if white has
a rook left but black has a rook and a
bishop
actually that should be a draw we saw it
in the uh in the
um skilling open a few times with the
indian player vidit
it should be a draw but black has these
two pawns and
two is better than one one of them is
going to become a queen
and i think maxine just
knowing him quite well we've played each
other so many times his body language
means he's
kind of resigned himself to defeat here
he knows the end is nigh
he'll be regretting that decision not to
take that um
that black pawn off the board a bit
earlier on
yeah this is yeah sometimes it's just uh
you should just accept what is in front
of you and not try to impose your will
you know because you can see
maxine russell craft he really wanted to
win he really wanted to push
he should have just accepted that the
position was a draw and because look at
it now
it's uh all going in one direction for
black look at that
it's just beautiful one of those pawns
are just going to queen
that's right and um black he's not in a
rush uh napoleon actually that black
rock just steps up
one square he's keeping an eye on his
bishop um the black
rook protecting its bishop that's
another good
tip for everyone at home just keep
everything nicely protected don't rush
too much the blackrook doing a
multi-purpose job right now
it's keeping an eye on the white pawn
and it's also keeping an eye on its
bishop
meanwhile those two black pawns i feel
so sorry for
that white rook one of those pawns is
going to
promote white will have to give up his
rook um to get rid of the new queen and
then the
other black pawn will win the game and i
think now is probably a good moment
uh black can push one of those pawns
forward and make a new queen we could
see
technically we could see three balls uh
three queens on the board right now
we could see it okay we're going to see
the first one appear so
now we're expecting rick takes queen or
perhaps a
maxim master legrove will just resign i
think there's a couple of options for
maximum vacuum
he captures the bishops so he's trying
to distract um black's rook
so black's rook no longer keeping an eye
on that white pawn
however it won't be enough we will
emerge actually maxine vasily grab i
think he's resigned
black would emerge with an extra rook
after both sides promote so
for example the rook white rook would
take the queen black's king would
capture back
but then black would make a new queen
white would make a new queen too but
black would be a rook ahead
wow so that is that is a win for janna
pomney actually
yes the final game of the day a
devastating loss for maximum vaccine
we are joined by another player who got
a win in his
uh his last game of today daniel dubo
congratulations
on your win against uh david anton thank
you very much
tell us how what has this day been like
your your very first champions chess
tour tournament
um well it's been it's been chaotic you
know because uh for like
first two or three games i was just uh i
mean first of all i had to play chess
and secondly i was just trying to fix
some uh
technical things with with my laptop for
uh
like for a better connection and a
better camera sync and everything
and everything so i was actually happy
with uh
with a three i mean with two boring
draws and one
like not that boring but still quite a
short
quite quite a short draw against maxine
and then
yeah i mean finally
you probably expect me to say is that i
finally managed since then i could play
normally but then i
finally just give up i realized i cannot
fix it at all i'll probably do it after
yeah after the the games are over and
then i just decided to play one um
one more uh i don't know interesting
game i don't know if if i played well
but i mean in general it was uh
yeah it was great fun i don't know maybe
i was losing maybe all stuff
i was doing was actually okay but in
general it felt like a tremendous joy to
you know to play such a game after yeah
after first stream
of boring draws and everything so yeah
that's it
so daniel we saw we actually saw the
second half of that game against david
anton it looked like exciting stuff
one thing that we noticed is that you
seem to have this knack of
somehow sacrificing material and always
getting a great position
especially with white how do you always
find that
kind of imagination to do that and how
do you feel always being a piece down uh
in most of your games well i mean it
feels normal
i don't know you know boris girlfriend
is my good friend so he
he basically taught me he likes to
repeat that basically if you sacrifice
more
more pieces and you'll blunder less you
know
so i mean if you sacrifice at least it's
not a blunder so yeah that's probably
that's probably my approach
but in general i don't know i just try
to play uh some
i don't know this decent opening is
white and then i try
not to retreat at any moment yeah so
basically if they attack your pieces you
you just have to attack back you don't
move your pieces
you you do something else so even in
this game i
i like this d4 d5 move i think it's very
stylish it's probably just bad but i
mean in general this g5 like
i have three three pieces under attack
or something then he
his piece is also hanging and then i
just go d5 like
like nothing is going on yeah i don't
know it was a cool cool game to play i
i actually haven't checked it yet so
maybe yeah my beat was like minus five
or something
and and we are actually now joined by
our fellow russian nayana pognati now
daniel great ending to the day for
for the the russians are you you
liking the time where you are sitting
now it's uh well eight nine ten o'clock
for you guys
hi um thank you for joining us as well
and congratulations on
winning your last game thank you thank
you was
unexpected but uh yeah is it actually
like that uh daniel with
so many russians being in top of chess
are you actually following each other
and maybe
sharing a little bit for each other are
you all just competitors
you know there are too many too many of
us for
for being either competitors or cheering
you know i mean it's just
thousands of people play uh playing
chess well in russia so you know
just yeah we have to leave we have to
live with this yes
that's it at least i mean only thing i
can add i could
let's say i gave my point you know
well-heartedly to sasha so
it's um
actually in the russian championship uh
recently daniel's
win in the last round actually helped
you yan to
win the title so um does that kind of
breed this greater well
great uh russian dominance exactly yeah
well but you know like uh two rounds
before this last round daniel also made
everything for me not during the title
yes sir
it's like very very very very
double-edged yes sir you never know if
uh you know
someone is your friend or foe yeah
actually actually if
you think he's a fall but turns out he's
a friend
and actually well you you two will be
playing each other at
one point danny what is it going to be
like to play against jan
i'm not sure if it's tomorrow or in two
days
i think it's in two days yes i think
you're right i think yeah in the end of
the preliminaries you guys will be
facing each other
yeah i don't know i think it's good is
it it's going to be like one of
uh like a dozen of games yeah i mean
we've played a lot and we'll probably
play a lot so yeah you know
so with some pleasant to play janice
grishop pointed out one so you can beat
him but you can now enjoy the game
fantastic and and what do you find most
enjoyable about playing online chess
well it's you know that there's
there is basically nothing to enjoy you
are nervous all the time so
you play like four games uh in four
hours before we have games you are
getting crushed every time again only
this is like very like
normally it's it's the opposite
um all right john it's been a bit of a
roller coaster for you today two draws
you had
ended it with a win but you also had one
loss what has this first day of the
um the everything's masters been like
for you
well you know to begin with uh in my
first game against tanish i just
occasionally made
the second move of the line i wanted to
play knight e5 and then bishop g4
and then okay i saw the bishop before it
before so i just wanted to resign at
first
and then i think i thought okay maybe i
can take play five and maybe it's not
over yet here so i was very lucky
in the second game sasha played just
great i believe
in the third game i was just really
tilted and in the wharf game i just
blundered i was ready to resign but
somehow i
uh i don't know i won in the end so well
uh
it's definitely not the time to you know
whine too much that's good
and daniel um tomorrow first game of the
day for you will be against
world champion magnus carlson a player
that we know you know
very well you are in his coaching in his
second team what will happen game be
like for you
we'll see but in general it's always a
great fun i mean it's one of the reasons
why i actually like this uh
this is magnus magnus store thing
because i mean
it doesn't even matter like normally you
need to play
very well to play him and then i mean
even when when you play well i mean
sometimes you you manage to somehow
avoid this game
and here it's exactly the opposite you
can play like an idiot but then you
still
still get this gift of playing partners
so i mean i don't
like to play him very much it's always a
very tense game i mean i just like it
i mean it's always exciting to you know
to play him
and john obviously you also played
magnus so many times i think you're one
of few players with a plus score against
the world champion
what's your final tip for daniel before
he faces the world champion today
tomorrow
well i think you know daniel is probably
the last person who needs my tips
all right well both of you thank you so
much for joining us and good luck
on the second day of their things
masters tomorrow thanks thank you
all right some some russian power there
definitely some of the best chess
players in the world come from russia
yeah definitely they have such a great
atmosphere they work together they study
together
and you see if they're competitive with
each other at the same time it's
absolutely brilliant
we actually see that in the queen's
gambit the netflix areas that we
mentioned a lot
that the americans talk about the
russians being
they're such a good team they're always
helping each other is that actually what
it's like in the real world as well
i think it's just the culture over there
i mean chess is this kind of
almost national sports in a way i mean
daniel alluded to it there's thousands
of great players in the country
i mean i've heard that even taxi drivers
are pretty pretty good at chess
um yeah i just think it's just in their
mentality and also
i mean they're lucky they have so many
talented players and they all work
extremely hard
they have this drive to win yeah i'm
loving watching their games
yeah the russians ending the first day
of their things monsters on a high note
both of these players that we talked to
got to win in the last game and
this is what the the fourth round ended
up um
like we did see um uh janupomniachis as
we mentioned win against maximum vagiela
grav
we had to draw between levonaroni and
hikaru nakamura
also a draw between wesley so and
alexander grishock another russian
timor jabo and anish gary also played
the draw and so
did pantala hari krishna and magnus
carlsen who's only played draws today
but then
daniel dubo as we mentioned he won
against david anton
and we uh i think
maybe we do have the standings list as
well let's take a look at that it is so
tight after one day
we actually have five players on two and
a half points and
there is only 11 rounds in the
preliminary so yes
everything to play for it is so tight at
the top five leaders
and then of course you have players on
two points you know chasing behind them
so
absolutely everything to play for over
the next two days i think it's gonna be
great
yeah and but and even for a niche gear
with it being this tight
david it's not over for him even that's
right i mean he's only one point away
from the
uh from the qualification places so just
stringing together one maybe two wins
um that'll be enough to elevate him up
um to qualify for that top eight and
i think nobody's safe here magnus
carlson in seventh place
i mean if if he just has one bad game
and that could happen i mean imagine if
daniel dubois beats him suddenly magnus
carlsen will be talking about
his survival chances anything can happen
and that's the beauty of this format
all right we do have a great uh day of
chess coming up tomorrow day two of the
air things monsters
some players really need to start
winning the games javanco yeah
definitely some players have had an
unfortunate start
but it is day one we are still two days
left in the preliminary stage and you
have to remember eight
of the twelve players will go on through
to the knockout stage so the chances are
good
just have to keep the nerves yes all
right well um
not only the players who've been
competing today we did have a twitter
quiz
as well asking um who is the current or
reigning
official random world champion and the
answer ivanka is the answer was of
course and many people guessed it
grand master wesley so who convincingly
defeated magnus carlsen it was just epic
what he did
and the winner of our quiz is
john johan who has won one year's
premium membership on chess24
and a brilliant prize brilliant prize
and brilliant that he
he knew that uh great so we'll have a
new quiz tomorrow for all the viewers
out there
perfect okay uh that was data one of the
first major in the champions chester air
things monster has been a good day
hasn't it
good to get started it's been a lot of
fun a bit of a roller coaster as well
some draws some really dramatic wins
we got see levon aronia's dog that was
my highlight
lots more to come as well hopefully
unboxing day so you're going straight to
your hotel and watching football i guess
oh
uh yeah studying some chests studying
some chess perfect
all right ladies and gentlemen thank you
so much for being with us here for the
first day of
the air things monsters luckily eight
days remain we have so much chest to
look forward to
we hope to see you again tomorrow and
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you